Thank you for listening to The Rest is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishist West, listen and you'll hear The voice of George C. Wallace, ringing loud and clear He's speaking to America, his words are wise and true And if you really love your country, here's what you'll do. Stand up for America. Let's vote to keep it free.
感谢收听《历史的 rest》。想要每周获取独家加更节目、无广告收听、剧集抢先体验，并加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请访问 therestishist West，听听，你会听到乔治·C·华莱士的声音，响亮而清晰 他正在对美国说话，他的话语明智而真诚 如果你真的热爱你的国家，你会这么做。为了美国挺身而出。让我们投票保持它的自由。
We're about to be destroyed by a great society. That was Stand Up for America by country singer Lamar Morris. And Dominic, he's from Alabama, like the hero of his song, George Wallace. He is indeed. So so far, Dominic, in this series, and we're looking at the politics of America in 1968, we've been very much focusing on the Democrats. And today we're looking at a man who, well, I mean, he ends up running against the Democrats in the 1968 election, but he does begin as a Democrat himself, doesn't he?
我们将被一个伟大的社会摧毁。那是乡村歌手拉马尔·莫里斯演唱的《为了美国挺身而出》。多米尼克，他是阿拉巴马人，就像他歌里的英雄乔治·华莱士一样。他的确是。所以多米尼克，到目前为止在这个系列中，我们在关注1968年美国的政治，我们非常专注于民主党。而今天我们关注的是一个，呃，我的意思是，他最终在1968年的选举中与民主党对立，但他自己确实是以民主党人的身份开始的，不是吗？
George Wallace, the hero of that wonderful song. He does. And that's because everybody in the South effectively was democratic. Because obviously in the aftermath of the Civil War, the Republican Party and in Reconstruction, it's the party of Lincoln, it's the party of occupation, it's the party of, as they would say, union aggression. So the Republican Party is tainted and basically to succeed in Southern political life, you have to be a Democrat. And Wallace, as you say, won office in Alabama as a Democrat, but then stands in 1968 for the so-called American Independent Party.
乔治·华莱士，那首美妙歌曲中的英雄。的确如此。那是因为南方每个人实际上都是民主党人。因为显然在内战之后，共和党人和在重建时期，它是林肯的党，它是占领的党，它是他们所说的联邦侵略的党。所以共和党是有污点的，基本上要在南方政治生活中取得成功，你必须成为一名民主党人。正如你所说，华莱士作为民主党人在阿拉巴马州赢得职位，但随后在1968年代表所谓的美国独立党参选。
So he is the champion of segregation and he is one of the most significant third party candidates in American history. He won 10 million votes in five southern states. So he's not an eccentric, he's not an outlier. And my view of George Wallace, Tom, is that he is one of the most significant American politicians of the 20th century. So far more significant than a lot of people who actually became president. And the reason for that is because the constituency that he finds and the themes that he makes play with establish kind of a new ideological bent for candidates, and particularly Republicans?
所以他是种族隔离的斗士，他是美国历史上最重要的第三方候选人之一。他在五个南方州赢得了100万张选票。所以他不是怪人，他不是局外人。汤姆，我对乔治·华莱士的看法是，他是20世纪美国最重要的政治家之一。比许多真正成为总统的人要重要得多。原因在于他找到的选民群体以及他所迎合的主题，为候选人，尤其是共和党人，确立了一种新的意识形态倾向？
Yeah, I think so. His campaign is often seen by political historians as an absolutely crucial moment in the transformation of the American political system. So the way in which the Republican Party becomes hegemonic in the South. But also you mentioned his themes and we will go into his extraordinary style, his rhetorical sort of flourishes, the country music actually that he uses, the iconography, all of those things. They very obviously anticipate later candidates and most obviously the one American politician who's been on people's minds for the last few years. And that is of course, Donald J Trump will be
是的，我想是的。政治历史学家通常认为他的竞选是美国政治体系转型中一个绝对至关重要的时刻。也就是共和党在南方成为霸主的途径。但你也提到了他的主题，我们将深入探讨他非凡的风格、他那修辞上的润饰、他实际使用的乡村音乐、肖像学，所有这些事情。它们非常明显地预示了后来的候选人，最明显的就是过去几年一直萦绕在人们脑海中的那位美国政治家。那当然就是唐纳德·J·特朗普，我们将
exploring the parallels between Wallace's career and Donald Trump's. Well goodness. Yeah. What a preface. Okay. So tell us about him. Who is he? And Dominic, I should warn you before you do that, that 1968 in America is obviously your mastermind subject. You did doctorate on it. You've read every book going on the subject. You've been into the archives. You've uncovered original material. However, as I alerted you in the first episode, I've read a single book. Wow. Amazing. Can I just quote? So this is by Luke A. Nickter, The Year That Broke Politics. And this is the guy who, even though he's not wearing a bow tie in his orthophoto, looks as though he should be. And he says of Wallace that he's one of the most
探讨华莱士的职业生涯与唐纳德·特朗普之间的相似之处。天哪。是的。多么棒的序言。好吧。那么给我们讲讲他。他是谁？多米尼克，在你这么做之前我得警告你，1968年的美国显然是你的拿手好戏。你为此写了博士论文。你看过关于这个主题的所有书籍。你进过档案馆。你发掘了原始材料。然而，正如我在第一集里提醒你的那样，我只看过一本书。哇。太惊人了。我能引用一下吗？这是卢克·A·尼克特的《打破政治的一年》。这就是那个虽然在他的证件照里没有戴领结，但看起来应该戴领结的家伙。他对华莱士的评价是，他是美国历史上最被
misunderstood politicians in American history. So just throwing that into the mix, because I think having read your notes, I'm slightly struggling to see how he could be misunderstood. Yes. I think Luke Nix says that Wallace has been a little bit maligned and a bit caricatured, does he not? He does. That's very much his theme. Yes. And we'll lay out some of the evidence and the listeners can make up their own
误解的政治家之一。所以只是把这个抛出来，因为我想读了你的笔记后，我有点难看出他怎么会被误解。是的。我想卢克·尼克斯说华莱士有点被诋毁和被讽刺了，不是吗？他是这么说的。这确实是他的主题。是的。我们会列出一些证据，听众们可以自己
minds. I think that's fair to say. Fair enough. So Wallace was born in 1919 in a place called Cleo, which was in what's called the Black Belt of Alabama, so-called the black soil, but also because it's the kind of heart of the kind of plantation system. So Cleo in the area around it, incredibly poor. It was always dependent on cotton. Six out of 10 people in that area are black,
做出判断。我觉得这样说很公平。好吧。华莱士于1919年出生在一个叫克利奥的地方，位于阿拉巴马州的所谓黑带区，之所以叫黑带是因为黑色的土壤，但也因为它是种植园系统的心脏地带。所以克利奥及周边地区极其贫困。它一直依赖棉花。该地区十分之六的人是黑人，
and almost half of those people in 1919 probably can't write their names. So that gives you a sort of sense of the poverty and deprivation of the area. It's an area, and it's a time period in which the shadow of the American Civil War hangs very heavy. So Wallace was brought up on the mythology of the lost cause that we did an episode about a couple of years ago. There are Confederate war memorials everywhere. There are Confederate graveyards and gravestones. The Confederate flag flies over the state house in Montgomery, Alabama. So he absolutely drinks deeply of that kind of legend. His father is poor. He's a farmer.
而在1919年，这些人中几乎有一半可能不会写自己的名字。这让你对该地区的贫困和剥夺有了一定感觉。这是一个美国内战的阴影挥之不去的地区和时期。所以华莱士是在我们几年前做过一期节目的“迷失cause”神话中长大的。到处都是邦联战争纪念碑。到处都有邦联墓地和墓碑。邦联旗帜在阿拉巴马州蒙哥马利的州议会大厦上飘扬。所以他绝对深深地吸收了这种传奇。他的父亲很穷。他是个农民。
He's a failure in the depression. It's interesting how many of the people actually in this 1968 story, Johnson, Nixon, Wallace, Reagan, yeah, Reagan, their fathers were failures who had struggled very badly in the early years of the 20th century. Is that why Wallace is an FDR fan? I think a lot of people in the South, I wouldn't say FDR fans, but they like the social programs. They like big governments. Yes.
他是大萧条时期的失败者。有趣的是，在这1968年的故事中，约翰逊、尼克松、华莱士、里根，是的，里根，他们的父亲居然都是在20世纪初苦苦挣扎的失败者。这就是为什么华莱士是FDR（罗斯福）的粉丝吗？我想南方很多人，我不会说是FDR的粉丝，但他们喜欢社会计划。他们喜欢大政府。是的。
So he's a paternalistic politician, I think you could say. George goes off to Tuscaloosa to the University of Alabama Law School. I've often had criticism because I use Tuscaloosa as kind of all purpose sort of American generic name to mean middle of nowhere America. So it's a delight to be able to use it properly. Yeah, well done. To mean itself because it's the home of the University of Alabama Law School. He goes there, his best thing is boxing actually. He's a brilliant boxer. He's a quarterback as well, isn't he? In the school football team. So he's good at sport. He's very pugnacious.
所以他是一个家长式的政治家，我想你可以这么说。乔治去塔斯卡卢萨上阿拉巴马大学法学院。我经常受到批评，因为我把塔斯卡卢萨当作万能的美国通用名称，用来指代美国虚无缥缈的偏远地区。所以很高兴能正确地使用它。是的，干得好。用来指代它本身，因为它是阿拉巴马大学法学院所在地。他去了那里，他最擅长的是拳击。他是个出色的拳击手。他也是个四分卫，不是吗？学校橄榄球队的。所以他擅长运动。他非常好斗。
Like me. No, he's nothing like you, Tom. I think it's fair to say. No, but in a sporting ability. I encourage you not to develop a parallel between yourself and George Wallace because I want the podcast to continue. Yeah, fine. Fine.
像我一样。不，你一点也不像他，汤姆。我觉得这样说很公平。不，但在运动能力上。我鼓励你不要在你自己和乔治·华莱士之间寻找相似之处，因为我想让播客继续下去。好吧。好吧。
But I'm just saying on the sporting field. He's a short guy. He's very pugnacious. He's not got much money, so he works as a kind of waiter and a short guy, he's very pugnacious, he's not got much money, so he works as a kind of waiter and a taxi driver while he's at university to make ends meet. And we're told in Dan Carter's brilliant biography, The Politics of Rage, that his classmates would quote, laugh at his shiny pants, loud suits, louder ties and desperate attempts to win friends. I think that's fair enough. In that respect, I think the parallel between
但我只是说在运动场上。他个子不高。非常好斗。他没有多少钱，所以在上大学期间，他靠做服务员和出租车司机来维持生计。丹·卡特在他出色的传记《愤怒的政治》中告诉我们，他的同班同学会“嘲笑他亮闪闪的裤子、浮夸的西装、更浮夸的领带以及拼命想交朋友的举动。”我想这很公平。在这方面，我认为
Wallace and yourself is... I think that's fair enough. In that respect, I think the parallel between Wallace and yourself is... I've never worn shiny pants. It's an exact one. Never ever worn shiny pants. He is passionately interested in politics. When he was 15, he won a competition and he really made a huge effort to win this competition to be a page for the summer. What is a page?
华莱士和你之间的相似之处……我想这很公平。在这方面，我认为华莱士和你之间的相似之处……我从来没穿过亮面裤子。这是一个确切的相似点。从来没有穿过亮面裤子。他对政治充满热情。15岁时，他赢得了一场比赛，他真的付出了巨大努力来赢得这场比赛，以便在夏天当一名参议员助理。什么是参议员助理？
Sort of carrying messages. Okay. You know, opening, closing doors and doors, and sort of just an attendant in the Alabama Senate. Because there's Kenneth Parcell in 30 Rock, he's a page. Right, I've never seen that. I've pretty much watched them all and I'd never knew what a page really is. Well now you know.
有点像送信的。好吧。你知道的，开门、关门，还有点像阿拉巴马州参议院的服务员。就像《我为喜剧狂》里的肯尼斯·帕塞尔，他是助理。好吧，我没看过那个。我基本上把它们都看过了，但我从来不知道助理到底是什么。现在你知道了。
Now I know. He's like a sort of errand boy, like a sort of office boy in the Alabama Senate. An office junior. Exactly. So politics in Alabama is, should we say, pretty distinctive. So politics in Alabama in the 1930s is very different from politics of Stanley Baldwin's Britain, let's say. Obviously, because Alabama was a slave state and a Confederate state has been subject to reconstruction and then what's called redemption. So since then, it has become a white supremacist, one party, democratic state. I mean that just for listeners now, that's the thing to keep in mind.
现在我知道了。他就像阿拉巴马州参议院的一个差使男孩，就像办公室杂工一样。办公室初级职员。完全正确。所以阿拉巴马州的政治，我们该怎么说呢，相当独特。所以20世纪30年代阿拉巴马州的政治与斯坦利·鲍德温的英国政治大不相同，比如说。显然，因为阿拉巴马州曾是一个蓄奴州和邦联州，经历过重建，然后是所谓的“赎回”。所以自那以后，它已经变成了一个白人至上、一党专政的民主党州。我的意思是，对于现在的听众来说，这是需要记住的一点。
The Democrats at this point in the South are very much not the woke party. They're not at all. They are the opposite. Since 1901, black citizens of Alabama have been systematically disenfranchised and they're effectively reduced to second class status. So you have segregation, the so-called Jim Crow system. The politics that remains is dominated by the old planters, the plantation owners and the new business interests developing at the turn of the century. And the tone of politics is aggressively populist. Politicians in the 1910s, 1920s, 1930s and Alabama
南方的民主党人在这个时期绝不是觉醒派政党。一点也不是。他们恰恰相反。自1901年以来，阿拉巴马州的黑人公民被系统性地剥夺了选举权，实际上沦为了二等公民。所以你有种族隔离制度，即所谓的吉姆·克劳制度。留存下来的政治由老种植园主、种植园主以及世纪之交发展起来的新商业利益主导。政治基调是激进的民粹主义。1910年代、1920年代、1930年代以及阿拉巴马州的政客们
will play on racism effectively and class grievances to mobilize a white electorate to win elections, but then when they're in office they will generally govern in accordance with the kind of business interests of the state. So racism is built into the politics of Alabama. Wallace never questions it, why would he? Most people don't. He had black neighbors, but they effectively lived a parallel life. There are stories about him at university arguing with northern classmates about the South's racial codes. And he's quoted as saying, the color define in their place, I don't hate them, but they're like children. And that is not something that is going to change. That's probably what a lot of Alabamians
会有效地利用种族主义和阶级不满来动员白人选民赢得选举，但当他们上台后，他们通常会按照该州的商业利益进行统治。所以种族主义内置于阿拉巴马州的政治中。华莱士从未质疑过这一点，他为什么要质疑？大多数人都没有。他有黑人邻居，但他们实际上过着平行的人生。有关于他在大学里与北方同学争论南方种族准则的故事。据引述他说：“肤色决定了他们的地位，我不恨他们，但他们就像小孩子一样。”而这并不是一件会改变的事情。这可能也是许多阿拉巴马人
would have said around about the same time, 1920s, 1930s. And is he thinking that because he's thinking that they're racially inferior or that they're culturally and socially inferior? That's a very good question. And I think you're asking a question that he would have struggled to answer because I don't think people... It's just the air that he's breathing in, right? Yeah, he wouldn't have intellectualized it, I suspect. Right, okay. But we will see later on when he's governor, what he writes privately about
在同一时期，即20世纪20年代、30年代会说的话。他这么想是因为他认为他们在种族上低人一等，还是认为他们在文化和社会上低人一等？这是一个很好的问题。我想你问了一个他会很难回答的问题，因为我不认为人们……这只是他呼吸的空气，对吧？是的，我猜他不会去理智化这一点。好吧，没问题。但我们稍后会看到当他成为州长时，他关于
this question of inferiority. Okay. And we can gauge it. He gets into local politics. He becomes a lawyer. He marries a girl called, of course, called Laureen, who is from Tuscaloosa, who has no interest in politics at all. Laureen will play a part later on.
这个问题私下写了什么。好的。我们可以衡量它。他进入了地方政治。他成为了一名律师。他娶了一个名叫劳琳的女孩，当然是来自塔斯卡卢萨，对政治毫无兴趣。劳琳稍后会发挥作用。
So remember her. She's very sweet. She's not a great brain. Everyone says she's very nice and George treats her generally, I think, very badly. There's a parallel with me that she's very keen on fishing apparently. Right. That's nice. Yeah. Throw that out as well. Okay. He became a flight engineer in the Pacific. He flew bombing raids over Japan. He came back to Alabama. He climbed the democratic ladder. He became a district judge and he attached himself to a patron called Big Jim.
所以记住她。她很甜美。智商不是很高。每个人都说她很好，而乔治对她总体来说，我认为非常糟糕。我和她有一个相似之处，就是她显然非常热衷于钓鱼。好吧。那挺好的。是的。也顺便提一下这个。好的。他成了太平洋战区的飞行工程师。他在日本上空执行轰炸任务。他回到阿拉巴马州。他顺着民主党的阶梯往上爬。他成为一名地区法官，并依附于一个名叫“大吉姆”的资助人。
Of course he did. Of course he did. Is there any other kind of patron in the 1950s Alabama? Surely not. So Big Jim, he was called Big Jim Folsom. He was the governor. He was a populist and he branded himself as the little man's big friend. And I'll just tell you about his rhetorical style. Dan Carter describes it as, and I quote, exaggeration, hyperbole,
他当然这么做了。他当然这么做了。50年代的阿拉巴马州还有别的资助人吗？当然没有。所以大吉姆，他叫大吉姆·福尔森。他是州长。他是个民粹主义者，他给自己打出的旗号是“小人物的大朋友”。我来给你讲讲他的 rhetorical 风格。丹·卡特将其描述为，我引用一下，夸张、修辞夸张、
ridicule, and a kind of country sarcasm that mocked his enemies. And you can maybe trace the lineage of that particular style, backwards and indeed forwards. But Big Jim had a drawback. He was moderate on race. He was not intensely racist. And the problem for him is that in 1954, there's a landmark Supreme Court decision called Brown versus the Board of Education, very famous to people who know about American history, which effectively said that segregated public schools were unconstitutional. This sort of sparks the drive to integrate schools and indeed other institutions. And this provoked a massive backlash across the white South. The foundation of all these white citizens councils pledged a massive resistance to defend
嘲讽，以及一种嘲笑政敌的乡村讽刺。你可以追溯这种特定风格的渊源，向后甚至是向前。但大吉姆有一个缺点。他在种族问题上是温和派。他不是极端的种族主义者。他的问题在于，在1954年，最高法院作出了一项具有里程碑意义的判决，名为“布朗诉教育委员会案”，了解美国历史的人都知道这非常著名，该判决实际上宣布隔离的公立学校违宪。这引发了推动学校以及其他机构实现一体化的浪潮。这在整个南方白人群体中引发了巨大的强烈反弹。所有这些白人公民委员会的基础都誓言要进行大规模抵抗，以捍卫
the southern way of life. And to give you a sense of how influential these councils were, within just a couple of years, Alabama's White Citizens Council had 80,000 members. But this is a time when to win the governorship of Alabama, to win the election, you probably need only 200,000 votes. So in other words, if you have the White Citizens Council on your side, you're almost halfway there. So Wallace abandons Big Jim at this point and starts to tack to what you might call the right. But he doesn't at first go quite far right enough. So in 1958, he stood for the governorship in the Democratic primaries, but there was
南方人的生活方式。为了让你了解这些委员会有多大影响力，在短短几年内，阿拉巴马州的白人公民委员会就拥有了8万名成员。但这是一个要赢得阿拉巴马州州长职位、赢得选举可能只需要20万张选票的时代。换句话说，如果你有白人公民委员会站在你这边，你就已经成功了一半。因此，华莱士在这个时候抛弃了大吉姆，开始转向你可能会称之为右翼的方向。但他起初没有向右走得足够远。所以在1958年，他在民主党初选中竞选州长，但有
a rival candidate called John Paterson who was even more overtly racist, even more, you know, pledged to the cause of massive resistance and was endorsed effectively by the Ku Klux Klan and Wallace lost to this guy, Patterson. So there's a very famous statement that Wallace says to his aides afterwards. He basically says, I'm never going to be outflanked on this issue again, expresses in much more earthy terms than I am. He does. Yeah. He says, I'm never going to be outflanked on this issue again, expresses in much more earthy terms than I am. He does. Yeah. He says, I will always be from this point onwards, I will make sure there is never a candidate to my right as it were. And so in the next four years, he goes out of his way to win white supremacist voters. He swings well to the rights on segregation. And he goes around saying to everybody, if the federal government
一个竞争对手叫约翰·帕特森，他更加公开地种族主义，更加（你知道的）誓言要进行大规模抵抗，并实际上得到了三K党的支持，华莱士输给了这个叫帕特森的家伙。所以有一个非常著名的说法，是华莱士事后对他的助手们说的。他基本上说，在这个问题上我再也不会被边缘化了，他用比我粗俗得多的词汇表达了这一点。他的确这么说了。是的。他说，从这一点开始我将永远如此，我要确保再也不会有候选人处于我的右翼。所以在接下来的四年里，他竭尽全力去争取白人至上主义选民。他在种族隔离问题上大大向右转。他到处对所有人说，如果联邦政府
and the courts try to integrate our schools, I will literally stand in the schoolhouse door to block it. And his radio ad, so this is 1962 governorship campaign, his radio ads pull no punches. Vote right, vote white, vote for the fighting judge. So he's the little man, the X-boxer with the shiny pants who is going to stand up to Washington and all of this stuff. Now you mentioned that guy, Luke Nickter, in his book in which he basically argues that Wallace has been maligned and people have overdone the race business and that really he's a populist, he's an anti-government populist. He does say that and so that notorious thing that Wallace says about not being outflanked
和法院试图整合我们的学校，我将字面意义上地站在学校大门前阻止它。他的广播广告——这是1962年的州长竞选——他的广播广告毫不留情。投票投给右翼，投票投给白人，投票给战斗法官。所以他是小人物，那个穿着亮面裤子的前拳击手，他将挺身而出对抗华盛顿以及所有这些东西。现在你提到了那个叫卢克·尼克特的家伙，在他的书中他基本上辩称华莱士被诽谤了，人们把种族问题搞得过火了，他实际上是一个民粹主义者，一个反政府的民粹主义者。他的确这么说了，所以华莱士关于不在右翼被超越的那个臭名昭著的说法，他说那是杜撰的
on the right, he says is apocryph right, he says it's apocryphal. Yeah, it is apocryphal, but perfectly plausible that he said it. I mean, how can we be certain that Churchill said any other things that are attributed to him? Well, we have to use our judgment. I think it's perfectly plausible that Wallace said it. So to give you a sense of where Wallace is, his speechwriter is a guy called Asa Carter. Asa Carter had been a ferociously racist and anti-Semitic radio presenter and journalist. He had founded his own Ku Klux Klan group in Alabama. This
对，他说那是杜撰的。是的，那是杜撰的，但他说了这一点完全是 plausibly（可能的）。我的意思是，我们怎么能确定丘吉尔说过归功于他的其他事情呢？好吧，我们得用我们的判断力。我认为华莱士说过这一点是完全可能的。为了让你了解华莱士的立场，他的演讲撰稿人是一个叫阿萨·卡特的人。阿萨·卡特曾是一个狂热的种族主义和反犹太主义电台节目主持人和记者。他在阿拉巴马州创立了自己的三K党组织。这个
group had attacked civil rights leaders. They'd attacked Nat King Cole when he came to Alabama. Not Nat King Cole. I know, very bad form. I mean, they had beaten people up and as a warning to what they called troublemakers, the group that Carter had founded had kidnapped a 33 year old handyman with learning difficulties called Judge Aaron. They kidnapped him, castrated him and poured turpentine over his wounds. Later on as governor, Wallace pardoned some of the men. So they were caught and convicted for that?
组织袭击了民权领袖。当纳王·科尔来到阿拉巴马州时，他们袭击了他。不是纳王·科尔。我知道，这太糟糕了。我的意思是，他们殴打过人，作为对他们所谓的 troublemakers（麻烦制造者）的警告，卡特创立的组织绑架了一名33岁、有学习障碍的杂工，名叫法官阿伦。他们绑架了他，阉割了他，并在他的伤口上倒了松节油。后来作为州长，华莱士赦免了其中一些人。所以他们被抓获并定罪了？
They were caught and convicted, exactly. Some of the men turned informant. They were not pardoned, but the ones who had held their silence, Wallace later pardoned them. Okay. Well, that's not looking good. I have to say, Luke A, Nick, doesn't mention that. Carter is the man who co-writes Wallace's inaugural address when he becomes
他们被抓获并定罪了，完全正确。其中一些人成了告密者。他们没有被赦免，但那些保持沉默的人，华莱士后来赦免了他们。好吧。嗯，这看起来不太妙。我必须说，卢克·A·尼克特没有提到这一点。卡特是与华莱士共同撰写就职演说的人，当他于
governor in January, 1963, it's an extraordinary piece of rhetoric. So Wallace stands up there in Montgomery and he says, and I quote, today, I have stood where once Jefferson Davis stood and took an oath to my people. It is very appropriate then that from this cradle of the Confederacy, this very heart of the great Anglo-Saxon Southland, we sound the drum for freedom. In the name of the greatest people that have ever trod this earth, I draw the line in the dust and toss the gauntlet before the feet of tyranny. And I say segregation now, segregation tomorrow, segregation forever. Now if you are a very conservative listener to this podcast, you might say this isn't
1963年1月成为州长时，那是一篇非凡的修辞作品。所以华莱士站在蒙哥马利说，我引述一下，“今天，我站在杰斐逊·戴维斯曾经站过的地方，向我的人民宣誓。因此，从这个邦联的发源地，这个伟大的盎格鲁-撒克逊南方腹地的心脏，我们为自由敲响战鼓，是非常合适的。以曾经踏上这片土地的最伟大人民的名义，我在尘土中划出一条线，将战挑抛向暴政的脚下。我说：现在的种族隔离，明天的种族隔离，永远的种族隔离。”现在，如果你是这个播客的非常保守的听众，你可能会说这其实
actually about race. This is about states' rights and freedom from federal intervention. And this is the liberty that is built into the American system and way of life. Frankly as an outsider, I find it impossible to make that kind of call because it's so obvious to me that racism is completely built into this. I mean, the way that that sort of peroration ends, segregation now, segregation tomorrow, segregation forever, I struggle to see how anybody can possibly claim that this is not about white supremacy and racism. Right, for example, there was a journalist from the North called Tony Heffernan who moved to Montgomery in 1961, spent a lot of time with Wallace and he wrote later, he says,
无关种族。这是关于各州的权利和免受联邦干预的自由。这就是内置于美国制度和生活方式中的自由。坦率地说，作为一个局外人，我发现很难做出那种判断，因为在我看来，种族主义完全内置于其中是如此显而易见。我的意思是，那段结语结束的方式——现在的种族隔离，明天的种族隔离，永远的种族隔离，我很难看出怎么会有人声称这与白人至上主义和种族主义无关。对，比如说，有一个来自北方的记者叫托尼·赫弗南，1961年搬到蒙哥马利，花了大量时间与华莱士在一起，他后来写道，他说，
when we met, when we go for a drink, and I quote, we didn't talk about women, we didn't talk about Alabama football, it was race, race, race, race. Every time that I was closeted alone with him, that is all we talked about. Maybe he's exaggerating. But on the other hand, Wallace's biographers have found letters that he wrote in 1963. He was asked for his views about black-white relations, and he said the best future in his mind would be complete segregation. He said black people were predisposed to criminality because, and I quote, the vast percentage of people who are infected with venereal diseases are people of the Negro race.
当我们见面时，当我们去喝一杯时，我引述一下，“我们不谈论女人，我们不谈论阿拉巴马橄榄球，全是种族，种族，种族，种族。每次我和他单独关在房间里，我们谈论的全部就是这个。”也许他在夸张。但另一方面，华莱士的传记作家发现了他在1963年写的信。有人问他对黑白关系的看法，他说他心目中最美好的未来将是完全的种族隔离。他说黑人更容易犯罪，因为，我引述一下，“感染性病的人中，绝大多数都是尼格罗种族的人。”
So they're lazy, he says, they're shiftless, but they're also, and I quote, more likely to commit atrocious acts of inhumanity, such as rape, assault, and murder. So that's what he's writing, right? In private, that's in private. That's in private. Exactly. Yeah. But also how does he govern? He sets up commissions to investigate civil rights leaders, to harass them, to harass organizations that are trying to register people to vote, for example. In Dan Carter's book, he describes how Wallace systematically
所以他说他们很懒惰，游手好闲，但他们也，我引述一下，“更有可能犯下令人发指的不人道行径，例如强奸、袭击和谋杀。”所以这就是他写的，对吧？私底下，那是在私底下。那是私底下。完全正确。是的。但他是如何执政的呢？他成立委员会去调查民权领袖，去骚扰他们，去骚扰那些试图登记人们投票的组织，比如。在丹·卡特的书中，他描述了华莱士如何系统性地
ignores correspondents from black Alabamians, especially if they're complaining about police brutality. And there's a historian who's worked on this very recently called Jeff Frederick, who's looked very closely at the Wallace administration. He says, and I quote, race was a staple of the Wallace administration connected to almost everyone and everything coming out of Montgomery. Race was used to pass legislation to create and maintain popularity, to build a war chest for future campaigns, to instill in white Alabamians a pathological fear of blacks and the federal government and quite simply for its own sake. The key moment for Wallace actually is about race in the national consciousness. So this is the summer of 1963.
忽视来自阿拉巴马黑人居民的信件，特别是如果他们是在抱怨警察暴力的话。最近有一位研究这一课题的历史学家叫杰夫·弗雷德里克，他非常密切地研究了华莱士政府。他说，我引述一下，“种族是华莱士政府的核心要素，与从蒙哥马利走出的几乎每个人和每件事都息息相关。种族被用来通过立法，建立和维持受欢迎度，为未来的竞选积累资金，向阿拉巴马白人灌输对黑人和联邦政府的病态恐惧，而简单来说，就是为了它自身的目的。”对华莱士来说，真正关键的时刻是关于国家意识形态中的种族问题。这就是1963年的夏天。
John F. Kennedy is under pressure from black grassroots campaigners. He wants to push through the integration of the University of Alabama. There are two black students, Vivian Malone and James Hood, who want to enroll. And Wallace fulfills his promise. He literally stands in the schoolhouse door with all the cameras around him to denounce what he calls the usurpation of power by the central government. And that makes him a national figure for the first time, the star, the poster boy, the champion of white southern resistance to civil rights.
约翰·F·肯尼迪正面临来自基层黑人活动人士的压力。他想推动阿拉巴马大学的种族融合。有两个黑人学生，薇薇安·马龙和詹姆斯·胡德，想要入学。华莱士兑现了他的承诺。他在所有摄像机的包围下，字面意义上地站在学校大门前，谴责他所谓的中央政府对权力的篡夺。这使他第一次成为一个国家级人物，明星、海报男孩、南方白人抵制民权的斗士。
But just to be clear, he is still a Democrat. Yes. Oh, yeah. So it's a Democrat resisting a Democrat president. You're talking about that as though you find that weird. I do find that weird. That's completely normal. The two great parties in American politics for most of the 20th century are not ideologically
但需要明确的是，他仍然是一名民主党人。是的。哦，是的。所以这是一个民主党人在抗拒一个民主党总统。你谈到这一点时，好像你觉得这很怪异。我确实觉得这很怪异。这完全正常。在20世纪的大部分时间里，美国政坛的两个大党并不是意识形态上
homogenous parties. But it's just that I suppose where the Democrats are now, it just seems such a kind of reversal. But the two parties now are very different beasts from what they were 50 or 100 years ago. I understand, but it is still just quite, I mean, because you're absolutely saturated in all this. But I think for outsiders listening to it is something just to emphasize. I mean, it is a real turnaround, isn't it? It is. So there is a church bombing in the autumn of 1963, four black girls in their early teens are killed by this bombing, a kind of clan bombing. The Northern papers blamed Wallace for this. They said he has fueled the flames of hatred. And what does Wallace do? Now a different person might
同质的政党。但这只是因为，我想就民主党现在的立场而言，这似乎是一种巨大的逆转。但现在的两党与50或100年前相比已经是截然不同的怪兽了。我明白，但它仍然相当，我的意思是，因为你对此绝对了如指掌。但我认为对于听着的局外人来说，这是需要强调的一点。我的意思是，这是一个真正的彻底转变，不是吗？确实如此。所以在1963年秋天发生了一起教堂爆炸案，四个十几岁的黑人女孩在这次炸弹袭击中丧生，这是一起类似三K党的爆炸案。北方报纸将此归咎于华莱士。他们说他煽动了仇恨之火。而华莱士做了什么？现在换作另一个人可能
have rode back at this point, but of course he's the fighting judge, the boxer. He just doubles down. He says the people who've created the climate of violence are, and I quote, the Supreme Court, the Kennedy administration and the civil rights agitators. So he is all in on this. So he at no point expresses any hesitation, any self-doubt, no, any anxiety that he might have contributed to this climate of violence. No, absolutely not. That's not his personality.
会在这个时候退缩，但当然他是战斗法官，拳击手。他只是变本加厉。他说造成暴力氛围的人是，我引述一下，“最高法院、肯尼迪政府和民权煽动者。”所以他全力支持这一点。因此他没有在任何时候表现出任何犹豫、任何自我怀疑、没有、没有任何他可能导致了这种暴力氛围的焦虑。不，绝对没有。这不是他的个性。
It's not his style. Right. It would be temperamentally alien to him to back down on this. OK, because he's pugnacious little fellow, but also he's surrounded by people who are saying, you know, you sock it to them, George. This is great. Stand up to the federal government. Okay. He is, by the way, enormously popular with white Alabamians at this point, and indeed enormously popular across the South. So he thinks to himself, I'll go a stage further. And in 1964, he decides that he will fly the flag for the South in the Democratic presidential
这不是他的风格。好吧。退缩在气质上对他来说是格格不入的。好的，因为他是个好斗的小家伙，但也因为他周围都是对他说“乔治，你给他们点颜色看看，这太棒了，挺身对抗联邦政府”的人。好吧。顺便说一句，此时他在阿拉巴马白人中非常受欢迎，实际上在整个南方也极其受欢迎。所以他心想，我要更进一步。1964年，他决定在民主党总统
primaries. Now at this point, Kennedy has been shot and everybody knows that Lyndon Johnson is going to be nominated on a tide of kind of sentimental support. And that he will be pushing civil rights. Yes. Wallace has nothing to lose. He takes his governor's plane up North. He paints over the Confederate flag on the plane with the flag of the United States. He changes the slogan on the plane, which was stand up for Alabama. He changes it to stand up for America. The 1968 song that we began with is called Stand Up for America. And he goes up to fight three Northern primaries in Wisconsin, Indiana, and Maryland.
初选中为南方摇旗呐喊。此时肯尼迪已经被枪杀，所有人都知道林登·约翰逊将在一种感伤的支持浪潮中被提名。而且他将推动民权运动。是的。华莱士没有什么可失去的。他把他的州长专机开到北方。他用美国国旗涂掉了飞机上的邦联旗帜。他把飞机上的标语从“为了阿拉巴马挺身而出”改成了“为了美国挺身而出”。我们开始时听到的1968年的歌曲就叫做《为了美国挺身而出》。他北上去参加威斯康星州、印第安纳州和马里兰州的三个北方初选。
Well, Maryland is kind of a border state, but it's north of the deep south. Now at the time, everybody thought, well, this is bonkers. The south had kind of been frozen out of presidential politics. It was still tainted for many years by the civil war and by the sense that southern politics was different and weird and nothing like northern politics. Well, I mean, I have to say, listening to what you're saying, they're not wrong. But when Wallace gets up to Wisconsin, as far north as you can get, right? On the Canadian border, the newspaper men following his campaign are stunned that he gets this very warm reaction.
好吧，马里兰州有点像边境州，但它在深南以北。当时，所有人都觉得，嗯，这太疯狂了。南方在某种程度上被排挤在总统政治之外。多年来，它仍然因内战以及南方政治与北方政治不同且怪异的观念而带有污点。好吧，我的意思是，我不得不说，听了你所说的话，他们并没有错。但当华莱士到达威斯康星州，到达你能去的最北端时，对吧？在加拿大边境，跟随他竞选的报社记者们震惊地发现他得到了如此热烈的反应。
He goes and addresses these people in these halls and they are blue collar people from Wisconsin, often of Eastern European extraction. They're very hawkish on foreign affairs. They say they're worried about crime and law and order and all these kinds of things. And as he rolls out all his usual lines, the Milwaukee Journal would say, you know, he rolls out his great sort of bullet points, if you like. The State Department has sold out to communism. The Supreme Court won't let you have prayers in public schools because it says it's unconstitutional. Thanks
他去向这些大厅里的人发表讲话，他们是来自威斯康星州的蓝领工人，通常有东欧血统。他们在外交事务上是强硬派。他们说他们担心犯罪、法律与秩序以及所有这类事情。当他抛出他所有常规的说辞时，密尔沃基《华盛顿邮报》会说，你知道的，他抛出了他那些伟大的要点，如果你愿意的话。国务院已经向共产主义出卖了自己。最高法院不准你们在公立学校祈祷，因为它说这违宪。多亏了
to the civil rights movement and the civil rights bills of this administration, there are going to be quotas at work, racial quotas. You're not going to be able to sell your house to who you want to. Your kids will be stuffed into classes full of strangers' children. And as he says all this, torrents and torrents of applause. Now the thing is, in these Northern campaigns, he never says anything overtly racist. But he doesn't need to because they're dog whistles. Here's the thing, and here's where I really disagree with Luke Nicter. Luke Nicter's argument would make sense if this was all happening in a vacuum and if
民权运动和本届政府的民权法案，工作岗位将会有配额，种族配额。你将无法把房子卖给你想卖的人。你的孩子将被塞进挤满陌生人孩子的班级里。当他说了这一切时，爆发出雷鸣般的掌声。问题是，在这些北方的竞选中，他从未说过任何公开的种族主义言论。但他不需要这么做，因为那是狗哨政治。事情是这样的，这也是我真正不同意卢克·尼克特的地方。如果这一切都发生在真空中，如果
nobody had ever read a newspaper. But everybody knows that George Wallace is the man who stood for segregation now, segregation tomorrow, segregation forever, right? He said it. So he walks in with that baggage. So everybody knows what he stands for. And he gets tremendous results in these three Northern primaries, 34% in Wisconsin, 30% in Indiana, and 43% in Maryland, which he would have won were it not for an unusually large turnout of black
从来没有人读过报纸，卢克·尼克特的论点就会说得通。但大家都知道乔治·华莱士就是那个主张“现在的种族隔离，明天的种族隔离，永远的种族隔离”的人，对吧？他说过。所以他带着这种包袱登场。因此每个人都知道他的立场。他在三个北方初选中取得了惊人的成绩，在威斯康星州获得34%，在印第安纳州获得30%，在马里兰州获得43%，如果不是因为黑人选民投票率异常高的话，他本来可以赢得马里兰州。
voters. And people are stunned at this, right? Because this is before the big riots in Newark and Detroit and the sort of darker turn of the 1960s. And political scientists, it challenged everything they thought about North and South being different and about how the future would mean the South ended up being more like the North. What they realized is that actually the North and the South are converging.
人们对此感到震惊，对吧？因为这发生在纽瓦克和底特律的大规模骚动以及20世纪60年代变得更加黑暗之前。政治科学家们，这挑战了他们关于南北方不同以及未来意味着南方最终会变得更像北方的所有想法。他们意识到实际上北方和南方正在趋同。
That in some ways the North is becoming more like the South because there's a guy called Samuel Lubell who writes about this sort of brilliant analysis. There's a guy called Samuel Lubell who wrote about this, sort of brilliant analysis. He said that in a lot of Northern towns and cities, what you have is Black families who have migrated over the generations from the South and now pressing up against white neighborhoods. And Lubell described it as a kind of frontline across American cities. And he said, that's where the Wallace vote is. It is the people who live on their frontline in those white neighborhoods who feel threatened by the black families
在某些方面，北方变得更像南方了，因为有一个叫萨缪尔·卢贝尔的人写过一篇关于这个的精彩分析。有一个叫萨缪尔·卢贝尔的人写过关于这个的精彩分析。他说，在许多北方的城镇和城市里，你拥有的是世世代代从南方迁移过来的黑人家庭，现在正挤向白人社区。卢贝尔将其描述为美国城市中的一条前线。他说，华莱士的选票就在那里。正是那些生活在白人社区前线上、感到受到向他们逼近的黑人家庭威胁的人。
who are pushing against them. And as we will see, this is going to be massively, massively important in the long run, because there are hundreds of thousands of people like this who are looking for somebody to, as they say, defend their interests and their neighbourhood and so on and so forth. Anyway, back to 1964, LBJ gets the nomination. Wallace is now enshrined in the public imagination as the great champion of the South, but he has a big problem. He's got a term limit, so he can't run again for governor of Alabama. Oh, he behaves very badly on this, doesn't he?
正如我们将看到的，从长远来看，这将会产生极其巨大的影响，因为有数十万这样的人正在寻找某人来，正如他们所说，捍卫他们的利益和社区等等。无论如何，回到1964年，LBJ（约翰逊）获得了提名。华莱士现在作为南方的伟大斗士被铭刻在公众的想象中，但他有一个大问题。他有任期限制，所以他不能再次竞选阿拉巴马州州长。哦，他在这件事上表现得很糟糕，不是吗？
He behaves appallingly. He's a bit like Putin getting Medvedev to run. Yeah, that's a good comparison. But I'm spoiling what he does, so tell people what he does. No, that's a very good comparison. So he pushes forward. I said everyone should remember her, Laureline. Laureline has been just a housewife all this time.
他表现得极其糟糕。他有点像普京让梅德韦杰夫参选。是的，这是一个很好的比较。但我剧透了他要做的事，所以告诉大家他做了什么。不，这是一个很好的比较。所以他向前推进。我说过每个人都应该记住她，劳琳。劳琳一直以来都只是一名家庭主妇。
Well, I said just a housewife, I don't mean to be sort of patronising towards her. She is very hard done by. She's a very sweet, shy, gentle person. She's completely non-political. Wallace is a dog, I think it's fair to say. He's always womanising and everybody knows about it and she's very hurt by it, but she would never leave him. And what is worse, in 1961, the doctors had been checking up on her and they'd discovered something suspicious. She had cancer effectively. And they didn't tell her. They told George, but he didn't tell her. He didn't pass on. That's not massively unusual.
好吧，我说只是一名家庭主妇，我并不是想对她表现出居高临下。她受到的待遇很糟。她是一个非常甜美、害羞、温柔的人。她完全不涉政治。乔治是个混蛋，我想这样说很公平。他总是拈花惹草，每个人都知道这件事，她为此深受伤害，但她永远不会离开他。更糟糕的是，1961年，医生们一直在为她做检查，他们发现了一些可疑的东西。实际上她得了癌症。他们没有告诉她。他们告诉了乔治，但他没有告诉她。他没有转告。这并不算太罕见。
Was like Peron, isn't it? With the Vita. Exactly. But in late 1965, she is definitely diagnosed with uterine cancer. She has to have a hysterectomy and she starts radiotherapy. Now this is the point at which Wallace says, by the way, you're having all this treatment, I want you to run for governor. Unbelievable. And she does because she does what George wants.
就像庇隆一样，不是吗？对埃娃。完全正确。但在1965年末，她被确诊患有子宫癌。她不得不切除子宫并开始接受放射治疗。现在这就是华莱士说的时候，顺便说一句，你在接受所有这些治疗，我想让你去竞选州长。难以置信。她照做了，因为她做乔治想让她做的事。
As Dan Carter says. While she's having radiotherapy. Yeah. She's just finished having it, I think. Dan Carter says, it was as though Laleen Wallace were a plaster Mary being carried through the streets on a Saint's Day parade preceding the faithful. That's how he describes poor Laleen who hates speaking in public or giving interviews, being kind of paraded around Alabama as a kind of front woman for George. She hates giving speeches. She would just read a very short speech, maybe 500 words.
正如丹·卡特所说。在她接受放射治疗的同时。是的。我想她刚做完。丹·卡特说，那情景就像劳琳·华莱士是一尊在圣徒日游行中穿过街道、走在信徒前面的石膏圣母玛利亚。他就是这样形容可怜的劳琳的，她讨厌在公共场合讲话或接受采访，却被当作乔治的门面人物在阿拉巴马州游街示众。她讨厌发表演讲。她只会宣读一篇非常简短的演讲，大概500字。
But she absolutely aces it, doesn't she? I mean, even so, that's the amazing thing. What, the election? Yeah. Yeah, of course. She wins a massive landslide, two to one landslide, because people know that they're voting really for George. It's not like they're idiots. Or do you think they like someone who's shy and doesn't really like giving speeches? I mean, that's the alternative possibility. Maybe they do. But George always gives a speech when it all leans events, right?
但她绝对表现出色，不是吗？我的意思是，即便如此，这才是最惊人的地方。什么，选举？是的。是的，当然。她以压倒性优势获胜，二比一的压倒性胜利，因为人们知道他们实际上是在为乔治投票。他们又不是白痴。还是你认为他们喜欢一个害羞、其实不喜欢发表演讲的人？我的意思是，这是另一种可能性。也许他们确实喜欢。但每当劳琳出席活动时，乔治总是会发表演讲，对吧？
She will just do a few words, then George will stand up and shout about people with beards and beatniks and Washington and all this stuff. So on the day of her inauguration, January, 1967, Wallace's men have a meeting and the people who are there are people from the White Citizens Councils, from kind of far right groups at the Liberty lobby, the conservative society of America. And they all pile in and they are talking about whether Wallace should run for the presidency in 68 as an independent candidate, not as a Democrat, mount his own campaign.
她只说几句话，然后乔治就会站起来，大喊大叫关于留胡子的人、垮掉的一代、华盛顿以及所有这些东西。所以在她就职的那天，1967年1月，华莱士的手下开了一个会，与会的人来自白人公民委员会、来自自由游说团等极右翼团体、美国保守派协会。他们全都涌进来，讨论华莱士是否应该作为独立候选人而不是民主党人参加68年的总统竞选，发起他自己的竞选。
Now, only a few years ago, this would have seemed mad for a Southerner to think of doing this, but in the intervening period, as we've described in previous episodes, you've had the Watts riots, you've had the birth of Black Power, you've had the riots in Newark and Detroit, a sense of the social fabric coming unstitched. And that is what Wallace is going to capitalize on. So there's the backlash element to that. But interestingly, and this I think is really important, this also has deeper roots because there has already been a kind of creeping southernization of political life and in recent years, historians have been looking at all
现在，就在几年前，对一个南方人来说，萌生这种想法简直是疯了，但在其间的这段时间里，正如我们在前几集里所描述的那样，你经历了瓦茨骚动，你经历了黑人权力的诞生，你经历了纽瓦克和底特律的骚动，一种社会结构正在瓦解的感觉。而这正是华莱士将要利用的。所以这其中有反弹的成分。但有趣的是，我认为这一点非常重要，这也有着更深的历史根源，因为政治生活已经在某种程度上悄然南方化了，近年来，历史学家们一直在研究所有
these grassroots groups that have been very popular since the 1950s in particular, Tom, this will please you, Christian groups. Well, Billy Graham. Billy Graham. He's already featured talking to Lyndon Johnson, hasn't he? But he's also very close to Nixon. So I mean, basically he's everywhere. He's endlessly popping in and chatting to presidential candidates.
这些自20世纪50年代以来非常受欢迎的基层组织，特别是，汤姆，你会喜欢这个，基督教组织。哦，比利·格雷姆。比利·格雷姆。他已经出场和林登·约翰逊交谈过了，不是吗？但他也跟尼克松非常亲近。所以我的意思是，基本上他无处不在。他不断地冒出来，和总统候选人闲聊。
And Billy Graham is a Southerner too. He's from North Carolina. And in the late forties and early fifties, Billy Graham had been much more conservative than a lot of people remember. So he had gone around denouncing, and I quote, the filthy, corrupt, ungodly, 40s and early 50s Billy Graham had been much more conservative than a lot of people remember. So he had gone around denouncing, and I quote, the filthy, corrupt, ungodly, unholy doctrine of world socialism, which would be news to Theo, our producer, who is very keen on that kind of politics. And Billy Graham had called for a purge of the pinks, the lavenders and
而且比利·格雷姆也是个南方人。他来自北卡罗来纳州。在40年代末和50年代初，比利·格雷姆比许多人记忆中的要保守得多。所以他到处谴责，我引述一下，“肮脏、腐败、不敬神的，在40年代末和50年代初，比利·格雷姆比许多人记忆中的要保守得多。所以他到处谴责，我引述一下，‘肮脏、腐败、不敬神的，”世界社会主义的邪恶教义”，这对于对那种政治非常热心的我们的制作人西奥来说将是个新闻。而且比利·格雷姆曾呼吁清洗粉红派、薰衣草派和
the reds who have sought refuge beneath the wings of the American eagle. And Graham was just one of lots of Southern preachers who did this. He slightly goes a bit, well a bit, I mean woke, I mean he doesn't go woke. He becomes a bit more vanilla. He mellows. But for example, there are much more extreme versions. So there's a guy, the most influential and the most important for Wallace is a guy called Billy James Hargis. Oh, he's brilliant. Are you familiar with his work, Tom?
那些在美利坚鹰翅下寻求庇护的红色分子。格雷姆只是众多这样做的南方布道者之一。他稍微变得有点，嗯，有点，我的意思是左翼，我的意思是说他并没有变左。他变得更大众化了一点。他成熟了。但例如，还有更极端的版本。所以有一个家伙，对华莱士最有影响力、最重要的人是一个叫比利·詹姆斯·哈吉斯的人。哦，他太棒了。你熟悉他的作品吗，汤姆？
I am because I wrote about fundamentalist Christian hostility to the Beatles. Yes, he hates the Beatles. Which kind of erupts in 1966. But one of his followers in 1965 published a pamphlet called Communism, Hypnotism and the Beatles, an analysis of the communist use of music, the communist master music plan. And his thesis basically was that the Beatles were communist stooges who were there to corrupt the youth and then the Reds would invade. So this is in 1965.
我很熟悉，因为我写过关于原教旨主义基督徒对披头士乐队的敌意的文章。是的，他讨厌披头士。这在1966年左右爆发了。但他的一个追随者在1965年出版了一本名为《共产主义、催眠术与披头士：分析共产主义对音乐的利用、共产主义音乐总体规划》的小册子。他的基本论点是，披头士乐队是共产主义的傀儡，他们的存在是为了腐蚀青年，然后红色分子就会入侵。所以这是在1965年。
So that's even before John Lennon has come out and said that the Beatles are bigger than Jesus. So Billy James Hargis had been going since the fifties. He had a thing called a Christian crusade. He had radio and TV stations across the country. Absolutely, as you say, Tom, the Beatles, rock and roll music, sex education, the Supreme court, and also civil rights. He says Martin Luther King is a communist. The civil rights movements is an attack on states rights. It's funded by the Kremlin. All of this stuff. It will amaze people to... I'm going to say yes. I mean, everyone will know what's coming.
所以这甚至还在约翰·列农跳出来说披头士比耶稣还受欢迎之前。因此，比利·詹姆斯·哈吉斯从50年代就开始活动了。他有一个叫基督教十字军的东西。他在全国各地拥有广播和电视台。完全如你所说，汤姆，披头士乐队、摇滚乐、性教育、最高法院，还有民权运动。他说马丁·路德·金是个共产主义者。民权运动是对州权的攻击。它是克里姆林宫资助的。所有这些东西。这会让人们大吃一惊……我要说是的。我的意思是，每个人都会知道接下来会发生什么。
That he gets caught up in a sex scandal. What do you think happens to Billy Tate and Sargis? But here's the thing. What this means is that thanks to him and people like him, by 67, 68, there was already this network of evangelical colleges and publishing houses and radio and TV stations, not just in the South, but across the whole United States. And this is what George Wallace is going to tap into. Crucially, his aides have learned something from Hargis, which is a fundraising technique using what's called direct mail.
他卷入了一场性丑闻。你觉得比利·泰特和萨尔吉斯会发生什么？但关键是。这意味着，多亏了他和像他这样的人，到67、68年，已经存在这样一个福音派学院、出版机构以及广播电视台的网络，不仅在南方，而且遍布整个美国。这就是乔治·华莱士将要利用的资源。至关重要的是，他的助手从哈吉斯那里学到了一招，那就是利用被称为直接邮件的筹款技术。
So this is basically a computerized system, very familiar to most of our American listeners. But this is the first time that a candidate uses it, right? It's one of the first times, right? So this is the age at which direct mail starts to get rolled out nationwide. You will be bombarded with letters saying, are you worried about, you know, tell you about an issue. Raw sex being taught in schools? Right. Are you? Yes. I am.
所以这基本上是一个电脑化的系统，对我们大多数美国听众来说非常熟悉。但这是候选人第一次使用它，对吧？这是第一次使用它，对吧？所以这是直接邮件开始在全国范围内推销的时代。你会轰炸式地收到信件，上面写着，你是否担心，你知道的，告诉你一个问题。学校里在教赤裸裸的性知识？对。你担心吗？是的。我很担心。
I'm very agitated about it. That's exactly it, Tom. Yeah. How do you feel about communists moving into your neighborhood and forcing your children to go to school with strangers' children? Are you worried about it? If so, dial 1-800-WALLACE and send us $10 now. Send us your tax dollars. Exactly.
我对此感到非常焦虑。完全正确，汤姆。是的。你对共产主义者搬进你的社区并强迫你的孩子和陌生人的孩子一起上学有什么感觉？你对此感到担心吗？如果是这样，请拨打1-800-WALLACE并现在给我们寄10美元。把你们的纳税钱寄给我们。没错。
And this is a brilliant way for him borrowing Hargis's themes. The idea of a liberal elite, a secular godless elite in alliance with communists and with kind of swanky people on the East Coast who are undermining the morals of small town America. With beards. It's a brilliant way for Wallace to take his themes and sort of slightly take the Southern edge off them and make them national themes. And so it is that three months after Lurleen's inauguration in April 1967, he goes on the top Sunday morning talk show, which is Meet the Press, NBC.
这是他借用哈吉斯的主题的一个绝妙方法。自由派精英、世俗的无神论精英与共产主义者以及东海岸那些削弱小镇美国道德的时髦人士结盟的想法。带着胡子的。这是华莱士将其主题融入其中，并稍微去除南方色彩，使其成为国家级主题的绝妙方式。因此，在勒琳于1967年4月就职三个月后，他上了全国广播公司（NBC）收视率最高的周日早间脱口秀节目《会见新闻界》。
And he says, I'm going to run as an independent. They say, are you a racist? No, I'm not a racist. He says, I'm fighting big government as an independent. They say, are you a racist? No, I'm not a racist. He says, I'm fighting big government. It's nothing to do with race. And he says, and I quote, he's a brilliant, popular speaker. He says, this is a campaign for the average man in the street, the man in the textile mill, the man in the steel mill, the barber, the beautician, the policeman on the beat,
他说，我要以独立身份参选。他们问，你是个种族主义者吗？不，我不是种族主义者。他说，我作为一个独立人士在与大政府作斗争。他们问，你是个种族主义者吗？不，我不是种族主义者。他说，我正在与大政府作斗争。这与种族无关。他说，我引述一下，他是一个绝妙的、广受欢迎的演讲者，他说，这是一场为了街头普通人的运动，纺织厂的工人、钢铁厂的工人、理发师、美容师、巡警，
the little businessman. And he says, these people have been ignored for too long and I'm going to give them a voice. And if the politicians get in the way, a lot of them are going to get run over. Goodness. Well, let's take a break. And when we come back, we'll find out if they are run over and how George Wallace does in his campaign in 1968 to become president of the United States of America. It is as if somewhere, sometime a while back, George Wallace had been awakened by a white
小商人。他说，这些人被忽视太久了，我要为他们发声。如果政客们挡路，他们中很多人会被碾过去的。天哪。好吧，我们休息一下。当我们回来时，我们将看看他们是否会被碾过去，以及乔治·华莱士在1968年竞选美利坚合众国总统时的表现如何。这就像在某处，某个时候的过去，乔治·华莱士被一种白色的
blinding vision. They all hate black people. All of them. They're all afraid. All of them. Great God. That's it. They're all Southern. The whole United States is Southern. So that was NBC's Douglas Kiker, who was covering George Wallace's presidential campaign in 1968. And I guess obviously there's a slight element of exaggeration there, but he is putting his finger on something important about what is making Wallace's campaign tick, right? Yeah, I think so. Wallace thinks, even if that is an exaggeration, he clearly thinks there are anxieties out there in states a long way from Alabama that he can exploit using similar kinds of sort of toned down rhetoric that he has been using in Alabama. And so this enables him to run what is effectively the most significant
耀眼幻象所唤醒。他们都讨厌黑人。所有人。他们都很害怕。所有人。天哪。就是这样。他们都是南方人。整个美国都是南方人。这就是NBC的道格拉斯·基克尔，他在1968年报道了乔治·华莱士的总统竞选。我想显然这里有一点夸张的成分，但他确实抓住了华莱士竞选能够成功的关键所在，对吧？是的，我想是的。华莱士认为，即使那是夸张，他显然认为在距离阿拉巴马州很远的各州里存在着焦虑情绪，他可以利用他在阿拉巴马州一直使用的那种经过淡化的修辞来加以利用。因此，这使他能够开展实际上是最重要的
third party campaign since Theodore Roosevelt's Bull Moose movement. Bull Moose, Tom. And we love a Bull Moose, don't we? You've been doing some secret reading, have you, to know about the Bull Moose? No, I haven't. I do vaguely know about Teddy Roosevelt. Okay. And I always remember Bull Moose as
自西奥多·罗斯福的“驼鹿党”运动以来最显著的第三方竞选活动。驼鹿党，汤姆。我们都喜欢驼鹿党，不是吗？你做了一些秘密阅读，是吗，为了解驼鹿党？不，我没有。我隐约知道特迪·罗斯福。好的。我总是记得驼鹿党是
being a pretty funny name. It just sticks in the mind. Surely he's part of the American Ryder Cup team. No, he's a police chief in 1950s Alabama, I thought. Yes, exactly. Now the thing is, the American system is not set up for three parties, it's set up for two. So all the different states have different sort of ballot requirements to basically stop a third party candidate getting on the ballot. And in total to get on all the ballots in every single state Wallace needs, I mean,
一个挺滑稽的名字。它就是让人过目难忘。他肯定是美国莱德杯球队的成员吧。不，我以为他是20世纪50年代阿拉巴马州的一个警察局长。对，没错。现在的问题是，美国的体制不是为三个政党设立的，而是为两个政党设立的。因此，所有不同的州都有各种不同的选票要求，基本上是为了阻止第三方候选人登上选票。总体而言，要在每一个州的选票上都印上华莱士的名字，我的意思是，
more than two million signatures. I mean, it's been estimated. Actually he ends up fighting all these court battles that make it a bit easier. But for example, in California, which is the biggest prize, he needs 66,000 signatures to get on the ballot. So people need to sign basically a petition. So his great focus as 1967 draws to a close is to get on that California ballot. So he's going to spend a lot of time in California. But there's a problem, a tragic problem. That summer Lurleen's doctors tell her that the cancer has spread.
需要超过两百万个签名。我的意思是，据估计。实际上，他最终打赢了所有这些法律诉讼，使这变得容易了一些。但例如，在加利福尼亚州，这是最大的奖项，他需要66,000个签名才能登上选票。所以人们基本上需要在一份请愿书上签名。因此，随着1967年接近尾声，他的主要焦点就是登上加州的选票。所以他要在加州花大量时间。但有个问题，一个悲惨的问题。那个夏天，勒琳的医生告诉她癌细胞已经扩散了。
She's going to have to go to Houston, Texas for surgery. And Wallace feels, although he probably doesn't really want to, he feels he has to go with her to Houston to kind of be at her side. So he spends two months in Houston. Then in the autumn, she comes back to Montgomery and she's obviously in a terrible state. She's very gaunt, she's very thin. But Wallace, at this point just goes straight off to California. Straight out to get support. So California, it's the home of hippies and Summer of Love and all that. Wouldn't seem obvious George Wallace campaigning land.
她不得不去德克萨斯州休斯敦做手术。华莱士觉得，尽管他可能并不是真的想去，但他觉得自己必须和她一起去休斯敦，以便陪伴在她身边。于是他在休斯敦待了两个月。然后到了秋天，她回到蒙哥马利，显然状态极差。她非常憔悴，非常瘦。但华莱士这时直接动身去了加州。直奔那里去争取支持。所以加州，那是嬉皮士和爱之夏的家园。乔治·华莱士去那里竞选似乎并不顺理成章。
It might not if you believe the Summer of Love propaganda as it were, but there's much more to California. I mean, California, you could write a whole history of the 1960s just in California and it would be brilliant. California is such a complicated and multi-layered place. First of all, California is full of so-called Okies, first and second generation migrants from states like Oklahoma, where Billy James Hargis came from. So these are migrants from the Dust Bowl who have brought often their religious values with them in the 1930s.
如果你相信爱之夏的宣传的话，可能确实不那么明显，但加利福尼亚还有更多内容。我的意思是，加利福尼亚，你单单凭加利福尼亚就能写一部完整的20世纪60年代史，而且会非常精彩。加利福尼亚是一个如此复杂且多层次的地方。首先，加利福尼亚到处都是所谓的“奥基人”，也就是来自俄克拉何马州等州的移民的第一代和第二代，比利·詹姆斯·哈吉斯就来自那里。所以这些是来自风沙区的移民，他们在20世纪30年代通常把他们的宗教价值观也带了过来。
So that kind of evangelical Christianity, there's a lot of that in California. California in the 1950s has been incredibly fertile territory for conservatives. So Reagan. Reagan, obviously. Yeah. Billy Graham, the John Birch Society. Lots of historians have written about this in recent years about all these kind of grassroots groups, they meet for coffee mornings and stuff and talk about how much they hate communism. That's all going on in California.
所以那种福音派基督教，加州有很多这种东西。20世纪50年代的加州一直是保守派极其肥沃的土壤。比如里根。里根，很显然。是的。比利·格雷姆，约翰·伯奇协会。近年来有很多历史学家写过关于这一切的文章，关于所有这些基层组织，他们聚在一起喝早茶之类的事情，谈论他们有多么讨厌共产主义。这一切都在加利福尼亚发生。
And people who put flowers in their hair, presumably as well. They don't like them either. And of course, Reagan has proved that in 1966. He has proved that California can be very fertile territory for a kind of conservative movement. Even so Wallace's rallies in California are like nothing people have seen before. He holds 70 of them in just a few weeks and they are in county fairs. They're in very unglamorous, they're places that basically, Tom, if you and I go to California,
还有那些头发里插着花的人，大概也是这样。他们也不喜欢这些人。当然，里根在1966年已经证明了这一点。他已经证明了加州可以成为某种保守派运动的肥沃土壤。即便如此，华莱士在加州的集会也是人们从未见过的。他在短短几周内举办了70场集会，而且都是在乡村集市上。它们是非常不引人注目的地方，基本上，汤姆，如果你和我去加州，
which we will do, of course. We will with the rest of history going to San Francisco and LA. Yeah. But we won't be hanging around, I trust, at strip malls, stock car racetracks, high school football stadiums, county fairgrounds and suburban car parks. Speak for yourself. I don't want to come across as a kind of East Coast liberal snob. Okay, good.
我们当然会去的。我们和历史的其他部分一起去旧金山和洛杉矶。是的。但我相信我们不会闲逛在露天购物中心、平地赛车场、高中橄榄球场、乡村集市和郊区停车场里。请代表你自己说话。我可不想给人留下一种东海岸自由派精英势利鬼的印象。好吧，很好。
But if you do, that's fine. A, I do want to come across like that. And B, I don't believe you will be going to strip mall car parks. Well, we'll see. Time will tell. And setting up shop there. Anyway, Wallace does, and his rallies would always start, there'd always be a cross-fingered political rally and a kind of gig, so a country music gig.
但如果你真要留下那种印象也没关系。第一，我确实想给人留下那种印象。第二，我不相信你会去露天购物中心的停车场。好吧，我们走着瞧。时间会证明一切。并在那里安营扎寨。不管怎样，华莱士去了，他的集会总是以一个交叉祈祷的政治集会和一个某种音乐会开始，也就是乡村音乐会。
And historians have also written tons, really interesting stuff about how country music, which obviously in Britain, we generally regard as risible. I was going to say it. What were you going to say? No, I'm not going to say it. You've gone lower than I would. But Americans take it very seriously, so I don't want to offend our American listeners. I mean, obviously I do, but country music is a massive signifier in the 60s and 70s of kind of conservative values. Right. And Dan Carter, Wallace's biographer, says it's the conservative voice of young white working class Americans.
历史学家们也写了大量非常有趣的东西，关于乡村音乐如何在英国通常被我们视为可笑的东西。我正要说呢。你刚想说什么？不，我什么也不说。你的底线比我还低。但美国人对此非常严肃，所以我不想冒犯我们的美国听众。我的意思是，我当然想冒犯，但乡村音乐在60年代和70年代是某种保守价值观的一个巨大标志。没错。华莱士的传记作家丹·卡特说，它是年轻白人美国工人阶级的保守声音。
So he kind of draws people with that. He really pioneers the use of country music in American politics. And it's very, very successful. In January 1968, he announces he hasn't got 66,000 signatures. He's got 100,000 signatures. And people are really astounded. Who knew that there were so many George Wallace supporters on the West Coast in the kind of great American utopia.
所以他通过这种方式吸引人们。他是美国政治中真正开拓乡村音乐应用先河的人。而且非常非常成功。1968年1月，他宣布他得到的不是66,000个签名。他得到了10,0000个签名。人们真的震惊了。谁能想到在伟大的美国乌托邦西海岸会有这么多的乔治·华莱士支持者呢。
Bad news, however, while he's been away, Lurleen has been fading fast. She has a series of operations in early 68, but she dies on the 6th of May. For once, Wallace is at home and he's holding her hand. When he's campaigning in California, he's like a kind of Buckingham Palace press release on the travails of an elderly royal, isn't he? Cause they were always saying, Oh, the queen is in good spirits while she's about to die and he's basically issuing the same stuff. Say, Oh, she's fine.
然而坏消息是，在他离开期间，勒琳的病情迅速恶化。她在68年初做了一系列手术，但她在5月6日去世了。破天荒地，华莱士当时在家，正握着她的手。当他在加州竞选时，他就像一个白金汉宫关于年迈王室成员坎坷经历的新闻稿一样，不是吗？因为他们总是说，哦，女王精神很好，虽然她快要死了，而他基本上也在发表同样性质的声明。说，哦，她很好。
She's brilliant. Vote for me. Here's another country and Western song. Exactly. So poor Laleen dies. There was then a sort of Eva Perron style jamboree in Montgomery. So all the schools close, most of the shops and businesses close on the day of the funeral, tens of thousands of people queue up to pay their respects. I mean, this
她太棒了。投我一票。这又是一首乡村西部歌曲。没错。所以可怜的勒琳去世了。蒙哥马利随后举行了一场类似于阿根廷贝隆夫人风格的盛会。因此，在葬礼当天，所有的学校都关门了，大部分商店和企业都关门了，成千上万的人排队致敬。我的意思是，这
is a sad detail. She had asked, she specifically said, I want my casket to be closed. And Wallace insisted that it be opened because obviously it's much better political theatre. More dramatic. Yeah. He takes a break for a few weeks and then the end of May 1968, he plunges straight back into the campaign, apparently untroubled by his wife's death, goes straight in in Memphis, Tennessee, 10,000 people queue for two hours to hear him say he's going to return control of schools to the people not, and I quote, some bearded Washington bureaucrat who can't even park a bicycle straight. This is one of his favourite lines and I can see you laughing. I mean, people are re-hooting with laughter
是一个悲伤的细节。她曾要求，她明确说过，我希望我的棺材是合上的。而华莱士坚持要把它打开，因为显然这样政治戏剧效果更好。更有戏剧性。是的。他休息了几个星期，然后在1968年5月底，他直接一头扎回了竞选中，似乎完全没有受到妻子去世的困扰，直接去了田纳西州孟菲斯，1万名市民排队两个小时，听他说他要把学校的控制权交还给人民，而不是像我引述的那样，“某个连自行车都停不直的留着胡子的华盛顿官僚”。这是他最喜欢的台词之一，我看得出来你在笑。我的意思是，人们都在放声大笑
at that. You know, this stuff about bearded bureaucrats who can't park a bicycle straight. Can you park a bicycle straight Tom? No, I can't. Well, but I haven't got a beard. So there is that. Okay. There is that. So one question might be, how does he pay for all this? Right. Where's the money coming from? Now his campaign costs about $9 million. So for context, that is cheaper than Eugene McCarthy's campaign for the Democratic nomination. And I think over the course of it, he generates a surplus. Yeah.
听到这个。你知道，关于那些连自行车都停不直的留着胡子的官僚的这些话。你能把自行车停直吗，汤姆？不，我不能。好吧，但我没有胡子。所以还有这个因素。好吧。还有这个因素。所以一个问题可能是，他这一切费用是怎么支付的呢？没错。钱是从哪儿来的呢？现在他的竞选花费大约是900万美元。因此，作为对比，这比尤金·麦卡锡争取民主党提名的竞选花费还要便宜。而且我认为在整个竞选过程中，他还产生了一笔盈余。是的。
His biggest single donor is a very shady man called Nelson Bunker Hunt. That's a made up name. Who is the son of an eccentric Texas oil billionaire called H.L. Hunt, who at one point was said to be the richest man in the world, but he's reclusive so no one's really heard of him. But 80% of Wallace's funds come from individual donors. And this is through direct mail. This is through people who've seen a special film they've had made called The Wallace Story, which is shown on small tiny little TV stations across the South and the Midwest. And people watch this film and it's interspersed with appeals for money.
他最大的单一捐赠者是一个非常可疑的人，名叫纳尔逊·邦克·汉特。这是一个虚构的名字。他是一个极具怪癖的得克萨斯石油亿万富翁H.L.汉特的儿子，H.L.汉特曾一度被认为世界上最富有的人，但他深居简出，所以基本上没人听说过他。但华莱士80%的资金来自个人捐赠者。这是通过直接邮件筹集的。这是通过人们观看他们制作的一部名为《华莱士的故事》的特别电影实现的，这部电影在南方和中西部的小型电视台播出。人们看了这部电影，其中穿插着筹款的呼吁。
And they ring the number and they donate money to the Wallace campaign. Do you know someone who puts up a Wallace for president sign in the gardens of his house? Oh, we've already mentioned him in the course of the series. And of course this is John Wayne. Elvis Presley. Elvis Presley. At Graceland. Yeah. Does he? Oh, Elvis. I looked up his biography just to see whether there was any George Wallace Elvis link and there was. I'm sad, but not massively surprised because I suppose Elvis is completely Wallace territory, right? I mean, he's from the right background. He's from the right state.
他们拨打这个电话号码，向华莱士的竞选活动捐款。你知道谁在他的花园里挂出了“支持华莱士竞选总统”的牌子吗？哦，我们在本系列节目中已经提到过他了。当然这个人就是约翰·韦恩。埃尔维斯·普雷斯利。埃尔维斯·普雷斯利。在格 Graceland。是的。他真的挂了吗？哦，埃尔维斯。我查了他的传记，只是为了看看是否有乔治·华莱士与埃尔维斯的联系，结果还真有。我很伤感，但并不感到十分惊讶，因为我想埃尔维斯完全属于华莱士的领地，对吧？我的意思是，他有着正确的背景。他来自正确的州。
Yeah, absolutely. Well, why do people back Wallace? What's he saying that is so powerful? What I think he does is he takes a lot of anxieties and he weaves them into a very simple, compelling populist narrative. So he takes the riots, he takes rising crime, he takes the campus protests, he takes the suffering of American GIs in Vietnam, he takes the kind of cultural change. And he basically says, this is all about you being betrayed by a corrupt, secular, sort
是的，绝对的。好吧，为什么人们支持华莱士？他说了什么如此具有吸引力？我认为他所做的是，他抓住了许多焦虑情绪，并将它们编织成一个非常简单、引人注目的民粹主义叙事。所以他抓住了骚动，抓住了不断上升的犯罪率，抓住了校园抗议活动，抓住了美国大兵在越南的痛苦，抓住了那种文化变革。他基本上说，这一切都是因为你们被一个腐败的、世俗的、某种
of socialist, rich elite. Make America great again, to a degree. Yes. The sort of paradigmatic Wallace quote is this. He says, you people work hard, you save your money, you teach your children to respect the law. But then when someone goes out and burns down half a city and murders someone, pseudo intellectuals explain it away, whining that the poor rioters didn't get any watermelon to eat when they
社会主义的、富有的精英阶层背叛了。让美国再次伟大，在某种程度上。是的。这种典型的华莱士名言是这样的。他说，你们这些人努力工作，你们攒下积蓄，你们教导孩子们尊重法律。但是，当有人走出去烧毁了半个城市并谋杀了一个人时，伪知识分子却在为之开脱，发牢骚说可怜的暴徒在他们
were 10 years old. That kind of watermelon touch I think gives you, it's obvious at that point what he means, right? He hasn't used the words, he hasn't said anything racist, obviously, but the code is right there. And it's also quite Reagan, isn't it? I mean, that's the language that Reagan had been using. It's very similar to Reagan's language in 1966. And there's a similar kind of folksiness to it. Yes, absolutely. It's just that Reagan is more genial, I guess.
10岁的时候没有吃到西瓜。我觉得这种西瓜梗让你，到那个时候他指的是什么就很明显了，对吧？他没有使用那些词，他显然没有说任何种族主义的话，但暗语就在那里。这也相当里根化，不是吗？我的意思是，那是里根一直在使用的语言。这与里根在1966年的语言非常相似。其中也有类似的一种平易近人的风格。是的，绝对的。只是里根可能更温和一些，我猜。
Reagan is funnier. Wallace is much keener probably than Reagan. Reagan likes to offer hope and optimism as well as to give hippies a bit of a kicking. Wallace's speech is really just a list of enemies. And if you go through them, Washington, he always goes on about bearded, beatnik, bureaucrats. He loves a bit of alliteration. And their inability to park bikes. Yes. He always says, when I'm in the White House, I will throw them and their briefcases. He's got something about their briefcases. He doesn't like their briefcases. I'll throw all of them and their briefcases into the Potomac. He doesn't like the courts, federal judges playing God. He hates universities, pointy headed professors.
里根更有趣。华莱士可能比里根更热衷于此。里根喜欢提供希望和乐观主义，同时也喜欢狠狠地教训嬉皮士一通。华莱士的演讲实际上只是一份敌人名单。如果你把他们过一遍，华盛顿，他总是喋喋不休地谈论留着胡子的垮掉派官僚。他非常喜欢押头韵。以及他们停不好自行车的能力。是的。他总是说，当我入主白宫时，我会把他们和他们的公文包。他跟他们的公文包过不去。他不喜欢他们的公文包。我会把他们所有人连同公文包一起扔进波托马克河。他不喜欢法院，联邦法官在扮演上帝。他恨大学，那些尖脑袋的教授。
And they don't know how to bicycle straight. No, no, no, no. And the media, liberal subsisters, intellectual morons, cause them at the media. Now here's where people may start to see some parallels. The press can't really decide what to do with Wallace. Do they paint him as a con man, a fraudster, or is he a fascist? Is he the Mussolini of the deep South? So Mussolini, not Hitler?
而且他们不知道怎么把自行车停直。不，不，不，不。还有媒体，自由主义寄生虫，知识分子白痴，他把媒体叫做这些。现在，人们可能会开始看到一些相似之处。媒体真的无法决定如何对待华莱士。他们是将他描绘成一个骗子、诈骗犯，还是他是一个法西斯分子？他是深南方的墨索里尼吗？所以是墨索里尼，而不是希特勒？
I would say... Hitler at this point hasn't become the kind of the default. Oh, he's bad. He's my enemy. He's Hitler. Well, actually he has because counter protesters shout, seek high at him. Okay. And make Nazi salutes and things. So yes, the shadow of Hitler is kind of hanging there. Wallace himself said to the authors of An American Melodrama, the Sunday Times team that worked on this brilliant book, he said to them, I don't talk about race or segregation anymore. We're talking about law
我想说……希特勒在当时还没有成为那种默认的角色。哦，他很坏。他是我的敌人。他是希特勒。好吧，实际上他已经是了，因为反抗议者会冲他高喊纳粹口号。好的。并做出纳粹礼等动作。所以是的，希特勒的阴影某种程度上悬在头顶。华莱士本人曾对《一场美国闹剧》的作者们说过，那是《星期日泰晤士报》的团队，他们写了这本精彩的书，他对他们说，我再也不谈论种族或隔离了。我们在谈论法律
and order and local control of schools, not these other things. Of course, the obvious point, which they make themselves is, but he doesn't need to use the word racist words because everyone knows he stands for it. And Wallace actually in an unguarded moment said to a journalist in Cleveland, race is the thing that's going to win this thing for me. He knows that race is part of the mix. But Luke Nickter is right about this. There is more to it than just racism because obviously crime has gone up by every metric. People are worried about pornography or cultural change or all of these kinds of things. I think Wallace
与秩序以及地方对学校的控制，而不是其他那些事情。当然，显而易见的一点，也就是他们自己指出的，但他不需要使用种族主义词汇，因为每个人都知道他代表什么。华莱士实际上在一次毫无防备的时候对克利夫兰的一位记者说，种族是为我赢得这场胜利的关键。他知道种族是其中组合的一部分。但卢克·尼克特在这方面是对的。这里面除了种族主义还有更多东西，因为显然犯罪率在各方面都在上升。人们担心色情制品、文化变革或所有这些类型的事情。我认为华莱士
is also tapping a deep-seated sort of strain of populism and indeed paranoia that runs right through American politics from the very beginning. I mean, you and I are in agreement, Tom, that the Declaration of Independence is a disgracefully paranoid conspiracy theory. But isn't it also the suspicion that people in the flyover states have of Eastern West Coast intellectuals and elites? Absolutely, it is. Which is a theme that is obviously very strong in the current election. It is exactly. But no, it's absolutely a resentment of cities, a resentment of the
也在利用一种根深蒂固的民粹主义，甚至是一种贯穿美国政治始终的、从一开始就存在的偏旁 paranoia（偏执）。我的意思是，你和我意见一致，汤姆，独立宣言是一个可耻的偏执阴谋论。但这难道不也是那些只能从飞机舷窗俯瞰各州的飞地州居民对东海岸和西海岸知识分子及精英的怀疑吗？绝对是的。这显然是当前大选中非常强烈的一个主题。完全是这样。不，这绝对是对城市的怨恨，对
kind of metropolitan elites, a resentment of the federal government, all of that stuff. These are of course, well-worn themes. They are Ronald Reagan's themes. Government is the problem, it's not the solution, all of that stuff. And there are possibly other comparisons. If you look at Wallace's speeches. So I was reading Dan Carter's book, which was published I think in the late 1990s.
大都市精英的怨恨，对联邦政府的怨恨，所有这些东西。这些当然都是陈词滥调的主题。它们是罗纳德·里根的主题。政府是问题所在，而不是解决方案，所有这些东西。可能还有其他的比较。如果你看看华莱士的演讲。所以当时我在读丹·卡特的书，这本书我想是在20世纪90年代末出版的。
And this is how he describes Wallace's speeches. He was the perfect mimetic orator, probing his audience's deepest fears and passions and articulating those emotions in a language and style they could understand. On paper, his speeches were stunningly disconnected, at times incoherent and always repetitious. But Wallace's followers reveled in the performance. They never tired of hearing the same lines again and again. Right. That remarkable, Tom?
他是这样描述华莱士的演讲的。他是一位完美的模仿型演说家，能够探究听众内心最深处的恐惧与激情，并用他们能够理解的语言和风格表达这些情感。在纸面上，他的演讲显得极其支离破碎，有时语无伦次，而且总是重复啰嗦。但华莱士的追随者们却陶醉于这种表演中。他们对一遍又听一遍相同的台词百听不厌。没错。这难道不引人注目吗，汤姆？
Yes. I mean, there's also, he loves hecklers. So he would say to people when they heckled, he would say, if you shut up and take off your sandals, I will autograph one of your sandals for you as a souvenir. And there was always a kind of latent simmering violence at his rallies. So hecklers would be beaten up or people would start throwing chairs and stuff. And again, that was part of the attraction. So part of the appeal of a Wallace rally is to have your prejudices confirmed.
是的。我的意思是，还有，他很喜欢台下的起哄者。所以当有人起哄时，他会对人们说，如果你闭嘴并脱下你的凉鞋，我会为你在一只凉鞋上签名作为纪念品。而且他的集会上总是有一种潜在的、暗流涌动的暴力气息。因此起哄者会被殴打，或者人们开始扔椅子之类的东西。这也是吸引力的一部分。所以参加华莱士集会的吸引力之一就是让你的偏见得到证实。
It's partly to laugh at the enemies that you all share, but it's also this sort of sense that you're letting off steam.'s also this sort of sense that you're letting off steam. It's a kind of mutual performance. The guy standing at the front and you, the crowd. I mean, I don't think listeners need me to point out that there are more recent candidates of whom exactly the same is true. Yeah. So on paper, his speeches were stunningly disconnected at times incoherent and always repetitious. You quoted that, Dan Carter, on Wallace, but I mean, that is often what people report about Trump's speeches. But then actually when you listen to the speeches that he's giving,
部分是为了嘲笑你们共同的敌人，但这也是一种宣泄的感觉。这是一种相互的表演。站在前面的那个家伙和你，也就是人群。我的意思是，我想听众不需要我来指出，最近还有其他候选人也完全符合这种情况。是的。所以从纸面上看，他的演讲极其支离破碎，有时语无伦次，而且总是重复啰嗦。你引用了丹·卡特对华莱士的这段评价，但我的意思是，人们对特朗普演讲的报道往往也是这样的。但实际上，当你听他发表的演讲时，
you get a sense of the impact that these are dramatic performances. His ability to connect with his audience is not evident in the words on the page. Exactly. That it's the atmosphere, which reporters would always comment on. They'd say the atmosphere of these speeches is not like a Eugene McCarthy speech or a Hubert Humphrey speech or a Richard Nixon speech. It's slightly like a Bobby Kennedy though. Maybe there's more of a revivalist atmosphere. Absolutely. Kennedy's speeches. So that's probably the most similar of all the candidates. But with Wallace's speeches, there was always
你会感受到这些演讲所产生的影响，它们是戏剧性的表演。他与听众沟通的能力在纸面上的文字中是看不出来的。没错。这就是氛围，记者们总是对此评头论足。他们会说这些演讲的氛围不像尤金·麦卡锡的演讲，也不像休伯特·汉弗莱的演讲，更不像理查德·尼克松的演讲。它稍微有点像罗伯特·肯尼迪的演讲。也许有一种更浓厚的复兴集会氛围。绝对是的。肯尼迪的演讲。所以这可能是所有候选人中最相似的。但华莱士的演讲总是带有
the aggression, isn't there? And the fact that so much of it is about enemies. And he's unapologetic about that, isn't he? He thinks that violence has a place in politics in a way that is not normal, probably, for presidential candidates, openly to say. Not for presidential candidates, but is normal in the populist atmosphere of the Deep South. That is that the aggressive rhetoric, remember Big Jim? Yeah. Big Jim with his exaggerations, his hyperbole, everything over the top. That's how southerners speak.
攻击性，不是吗？而且其中很大一部分是关于敌人的。他对这一点毫不掩饰，不是吗？他认为暴力在政治中有一席之地，这种方式对于总统候选人来说可能是不寻常的，即公开这样说。对于总统候选人来说是不寻常的，但在深南方的民粹主义氛围中是寻常的。也就是说，那种激进的修辞，还记得大吉姆吗？是的。大吉姆总是夸大其词，使用夸张手法，一切都做得过头。南方人就是这样说话的。
But he's not running for president. Big Jim wasn't running for president. No. But what it is, is there a sense that a slight element of violence is being introduced? Yes, I think absolutely. And I think this is why so many Northern commentators are so horrified. And they're horrified when they look at the polls. So, you know, his dream scenario is he wins the entire former Confederacy.
但他不是在竞选总统。大吉姆没有竞选总统。没有。但是，这里面是不是有一种感觉，即微量的暴力正在被引入？是的，我绝对这么认为。我认为这就是为什么那么多北方评论员会如此惊恐的原因。当他们看到民调结果时，他们感到惊恐。所以，你知道，他梦想中的场景是他赢得了整个前邦联地区。
He wins the entire border state region. So that's a place like Maryland and Kentucky. And then he adds one or two Midwestern states like Indiana or Ohio. That's always unlikely, I think. Midwestern states like Indiana or Ohio. That's always unlikely, I think. Even so, at the start of October 1968, one in five Americans say they're going to vote for him. And he is hoping to win the South, maybe win a few of the border states. If he gets to about 150, 170 electoral college votes, the election will be deadlocked. It will have to go to the House of Representatives for the first time since the 1820s. And he can kind of be the kingmaker. That's what he wants. That's his dream.
他赢得了整个边境州地区。所以那是像马里兰州和肯塔基州这样的地方。然后他再加上一两个中西部州，比如印第安纳州或俄亥俄州。我认为这总是太不可能。中西部州比如印第安纳州或俄亥俄州。我认为这总是太不可能。即便如此，在1968年10月初，五分之一的美国人表示他们将投票给他。他希望能赢得南方，也许还能赢得一些边境州。如果他能获得大约150到170张选举人票，选举就会陷入僵局。它将自19世纪20年代以来首次提交给众议院决定。而他可以某种程度上成为政坛造王者。这就是他想要的。那是他的梦想。
What an extraordinary thing that would be that he decides the future of the American Republic. But there are two very comical developments, aren't there? So number one is the presence of this lady called Janine Welch. And I say Janine, she spells Janine. Like a Star Wars character. A-A-Hyphen-Capital N-E-E-N. And Janine is this sort of middle-aged woman who wears, quote, skin tight, silver and gold lame cowboy outfits. She's a groupie basically. She's got very close to Wallace. She's what the Clinton campaign would have called a bimbo eruption, right?
那是多么非凡的一件事啊，由他来决定美利坚共和国的未来。但有两个非常滑稽的发展，不是吗？所以第一件事就是这个名叫珍妮·韦奇的女士的出现。我说珍妮，她的拼写是珍妮。就像一个《星球大战》里的角色。A-A-连字符-大写N-E-E-N。珍妮就是那种中年女性，穿着，我引述一下，“紧身银色和金色的拉美风牛仔装”。她基本上是个追星族。她跟华莱士走得很近。她就是克林顿竞选团队所说的那种“桃色绯闻爆发”，对吧？
She is a bimbo eruption, exactly. And she starts sharing his hotel rooms, she's hanging around with him in public and stuff. And his aides are very agitated about this and say to Janine, can you please keep a lower profile? And she says, well, the big problem with this relationship is, and I quote, he's in such a hurry, sometimes he won't even take his coat off. Well that's commitment, isn't it? That is commitment. But basically they kick her off the campaign and so that's the end
她确实是一场桃色绯闻爆发，没错。她开始和他共用酒店房间，在公共场合和他鬼混之类的事情。他的助手对此非常焦虑，对珍妮说，你能保持低调一点吗？她说，好吧，这段关系最大的问题是，我引述一下，“他太急了，有时甚至连大衣都不脱。”这可以说是相当投入了，不是吗？这确实很投入。但基本上他们把她踢出了竞选团队，所以珍妮的故事就到此为止了，但她分散了他的注意力。好吧，她因涉嫌卖淫被捕了。她确实被捕了。你知道吗，我谷歌了她，我做了一些挖掘，我的意思是，这是一条进入了奇怪兔子洞的经历。她大约三个月前去世了。天哪。她当时80多岁了。
of Janine, but she distracts him. Well she gets arrested for prostitution. She does indeed. You know what, I Googled her, I did some digging, I mean this is a weird rabbit hole to have gone down. She died about three months ago. Oh God. She was in her 80s.
天哪。是的。珍妮·韦奇不是她的真名。她把名字改成了别的什么。这有点像当地社区备受爱戴的中流砥柱之类的事情。读到这些时我感到很糟糕，因为之前我还嘲笑过她的金色牛仔装什么的，但他也需要一个更常规的竞选搭档。这太棒了。所以他的首选是这个叫“快乐”钱德勒的家伙。整个故事就像一个英国人对美国政治的恶搞，不是吗？
Goodness. Yeah. Janine Welch was not her name. She changed her name to something else. And it sort of was like much loved pillar of local community and stuff. I felt awful reading this having laughed about her gold cowboy outfit or whatever, but he also needs a running mate of a more conventional kind. This is brilliant. So his first choice is this guy called Happy Chandler. The whole story is like a British person's parody of American politics, isn't it?
他的首选就是这个家伙，“快乐”钱德勒。快乐钱德勒，没错。他说得对，汤姆。他曾担任肯塔基州州长，后来又担任棒球专员。基本上，他并不是极其种族主义，因为他曾帮助推动棒球运动的种族融合。他在40年代支持杰基·罗宾逊与布鲁克林道奇队一起打球，这是棒球史上一个伟大的时刻。无论如何，极右翼人士对此提出了强烈抱怨。
His first choice is this guy, Happy Chandler. Happy Chandler, exactly. He's right, Tom. Who had been the governor of Kentucky and then the baseball commissioner. And basically, he's not immensely racist because he had helped integrate baseball. He had backed Jackie Robinson playing with the Brooklyn Dodgers in the 40s, which was this big moment in baseball's history. Anyway, there's huge complaints from the people on the far right.
所以纳尔逊·邦克·汉特。他不喜欢“快乐”钱德勒。是的。他说这家伙在种族这个核心问题上立场不够坚定，很显然。所以你不能要这个自由派的粉红家伙。于是他们甩掉了“快乐”钱德勒。他们选择了他们的第二人选。这大大增加了全国的欢乐气氛。所以他们的第二人选是柯蒂斯·勒梅将军。他曾是美国轰炸
So Nelson Bunker Hunt. He doesn't like Happy Chandler. Yeah. He says this guy's soft on the key issue of race, obviously. So you can't have this liberal, pinko fellow. So they ditch Happy Chandler. They go for their second choice. Which adds greatly to the gaiety of the nation. So their second choice is General Curtis LeMay. He'd been a former commander of US bombers
日本的轰炸机部队前指挥官。他曾担任战略空军司令部司令，后来最终成为了美国空军参谋长。他最著名的，我猜，如果你看过电影《奇爱博士》，他就是乔治·C·斯科特扮演的角色——巴克·特吉森将军的原型，直接灵感来源。他看起来就像是用木头做成的，从不笑，嘴里总是嚼着雪茄。他基本上是嬉皮士对美国空军终极恶梦般的幻想。对吧？完全是这样。
over Japan. He'd been the head of Strategic Air Command, and then he'd ended up as chief of staff of the US Air Force. His most famous, I guess, because if you've seen Dr. Strangelove, he was the model, the direct inspiration for the character played by George C. Scott, General Buck Turgidson. He looks like he's made of wood, he never smiles, he's always chewing a cigar. He's basically a hippie's kind of nightmare vision of what the US Air Force is all about. Right? Totally is.
因为他基本上喜欢轰炸别人。他怎么也炸不够。为他辩护的是，他说过一句我读过的最喜欢的句子。这其实也很符合我的实际情况。我一直力求尽量少屠杀平民。但我的意思是，关键是，他可能是对的。当你这样表达时，我的意思是，从政治上讲，这不是构建这句话的理想方式，但是……我尽量不屠杀太多人。
Because he basically loves bombing people. He can't get enough of it. In his defence, he said one of the favourite sentences I've ever read. That's actually very true of me as well. I've always sought to slaughter as few civilians as possible. But I mean, the thing is, he's probably right. When you put it like, I mean, politically, it's not the ideal way to frame it, but... I try not to slaughter too many people.
无论如何，他曾对越南战争说过，他解决该问题的办法是，我引述一下，“把他们炸回石器时代”。许多人认为这很不合政治体统。无论如何，他已经退休几年了。肯尼迪恨透了他，因为在古巴导弹危机之后，他说，我们难道不应该无论如何直接轰炸古巴吗？是的。他当时的反应是，不。
Anyway, he had said of the Vietnam War, his solution for it was to, and I quote, bomb them back into the stone age. And a lot of people thought this was very impolitic. Anyway, he's been retired for a few years. Kennedy hated him because after the Cuban Missile Crisis, he said, should we just bomb Cuba anyway? Yeah. He was like, no.
无论如何，他本在考虑投票给尼克松，但他太喜欢成为华莱士副总统候选人的想法了，因为这是他的机会：A，羞辱美国的左翼分子；B，推动他情有独钟的十字军东征，我们一会儿就会谈到这一点。所以他将于10月3日在匹兹堡希尔顿酒店亮相。如果我说这非常像“四季园林绿化公司”（Four Seasons Total landscaping），我们的美国听众就会明白这意味着什么。所以基本上在前一天晚上，勒梅在这个酒店与华莱士的助手们会面，他们问，你打算说些什么？他说，很明显我要谈论核武器。
Anyway, he'd been thinking about voting for Nixon, but he loves the thought of being Wallace's vice president because it's his chance to A, have a go at left wingers in America, but also to push his pet crusade, which we should get onto in a minute. So he's going to be unveiled at the Pittsburgh Hilton on the 3rd of October. And if I say this is very four seasons total landscaping, our American listeners will know what this means. So basically the night before, LeMay meets up in this hotel with Wallace's aides and they say, what are you going to say? And he says, well, obviously I'm going to be talking about nuclear weapons.
原因是他认为核武器应该比过去更经常地被使用。这就是他的主张。人们，我引述一下，“对它们有一种愚密的恐惧症”。他们需要拿出点男子气概来。而华莱士的助手们，你知道，我的意思是，让我们明确一点，华莱士的助手们绝不是什么心慈手软的自由派。情况更像是，不，不，不。请千万不要提起这个。由于他对这一点如此执着，
And the reason for that is that he thinks they should be used more often than they have been. That's his pitch. People have, and I quote, a foolish phobia about them. They need to man up. And the Wallace aides, you know, I mean, let's be clear, the Wallace aides are hardly bleeding hearted liberals. It's just like, no, no, no. Please do not bring this up. And because he's so attached to this,
原因在于，他认为这些方法的应用应该比以往更加频繁。这就是他的推销说辞。人们对它们有一种——我引用一下——“愚蠢的恐惧症”。他们需要振作起来。华莱士的助手们，你知道的，我的意思是，说句实话，华莱士的助手们可绝不是什么心慈手软的自由派。他们的态度就像是：不，不，不。请千万别把这个提出来。而且因为他对这一点如此执着，
they end up staying up with him until four 30 in the morning begging. And they say, don't talk about it. Please don't talk about it. Don't mention it. Then he goes in to his press conference and the first question is from the Los Angeles Times. General, do you think it is necessary to use nuclear weapons to win the war in Vietnam. All of Wallace's aides holding their breath. He piles in, doesn't he? But at first he taunts them though, because he says right at the beginning, we can win this war without nuclear weapons. But I have to say that we have a phobia about nuclear weapons. I think there may be times when it would be most efficient to use nuclear weapons.
他们最终陪着他熬夜到凌晨四点半，苦苦哀求。他们说，别谈这个。求你别谈这个。别提它。然后他走进新闻发布会，第一个问题来自《洛杉矶时报》。将军，你认为有必要在越南战争中使用核武器来取胜吗？华莱士的所有助手都屏住了呼吸。他一头扎进去了，不是吗？但一开始他还是戏弄了他们，因为他在一开始就说，我们不用核武器也能赢得这场战争。但我必须说，我们对核武器有一种恐惧症。我认为有时使用核武器可能是最有效的方法。
However, the public opinion in this country and through the world throw up their hands in horror when you mention nuclear weapons just because of the propaganda that's been fed to them. Brilliant stuff. That's his first answer. Will Barron Wallace is just in shock. Now Wallace is so garrulous usually when he says nothing. he's appalled. There are these hilarious descriptions of reporters sort of scrabbling and fighting. Running off to the phone boxes. To ring the newspaper. But if they do that, they miss the even better bit that's coming up. He doesn't leave this
然而，只要你一提到核武器，这个国家乃至全世界的公众就会吓得双手抱头，惊恐万分，这全是因为灌输给他们的宣传。精彩绝伦。这是他的第一个回答。威尔·巴伦·华莱士简直惊呆了。现在华莱士通常在什么都不说时总是滔滔不绝。他被吓呆了。有一些关于记者们如何争先恐后、打架斗殴的搞笑描述。争先恐后地跑向电话亭。给报社打电话。但如果他们这么做了，他们就会错过即将上演的更精彩的部分。他并没有就此罢休
theme alone, does he? And he then goes on, I've seen a film of Bikini Adol after 20 nuclear tests and the fish are all back in the lagoons, the coconut trees are growing coconuts, the guava bushes have fruit on them, the birds are back. Then he comes up with the one slight caveat, the rats are bigger, fatter and healthier than they ever were before. So at this point Wallace jumps in and he says, just to be clear, General LeMay is not advocating the use of nuclear weapons, he is just discussing nuclear weapons.
这个主题，对吧？然后他继续说道，我看过比基尼环礁在进行了20次核试爆后的电影，鱼儿都回到了泻湖里，椰子树长出了椰子，番石榴树上挂满了果实，鸟儿也回来了。然后他提出了一个细微的警告，老鼠比以往任何时候都更大、更胖、更健康。所以此时华莱士插话道，为了把话说清楚，柯梅尔将军并不主张使用核武器，他只是在讨论核武器。
Well, wait a minute now. I know I'm going to come out with a lot of misquotes from the campaign. I'll be lucky if I don't appear as a drooling idiot whose only solution to any problem is to drop atomic bombs all over the world. I assure you I'm not. And so that must be a comfort. Yeah. So Wallace is apparently absolutely distraught about this. I mean, it does kind of slightly hold him below the water, doesn't it? It does completely because it makes him a complete joke. It makes his campaign a total joke that they've got this guy.
好吧，等等。我知道我在竞选过程中会说出很多被断章取义的话。如果我没有变成一个流着口水的白痴，而他解决任何问题的唯一办法就是在全世界到处扔原子弹，那我可就太幸运了。我向你们保证我不是。所以这一定是个安慰。是的。所以华莱士显然为此感到绝对心烦意乱。我的意思是，这确实在一定程度上让他陷入了困境，不是吗？确实如此，因为这让他变成了一个彻头彻尾的笑柄，让他的竞选活动变成了一个彻底的笑话，因为他们选了这家伙。
This mad bloke. Doesn't Wallace pack him off on a kind of fact-finding tour of Vietnam or something to just keep him out of the way? First, they sent him to most obscure locations in America to give speeches about environmental protection. But he went up somewhere to some Northeastern college and people asked him about population. He said, people should have more abortions. That's the solution to the growing population. And if they don't, nuke him.
这个疯子。华莱士难道不是把他打发去对越南进行某种实地考察之类的旅行，好让他别来碍事吗？起初，他们把他派往美国最偏僻的地方去发表关于环境保护的演讲。但他去了东北部的某所大学，人们问他关于人口的问题。他说，人们应该多做几次流产。那是解决人口不断增长的办法。如果不这样做，就用核武器炸死他们。
And this obviously does not play well with Wallace's constituency at all. So it's at that point they said, send him to Vietnam and let's hope he never comes back. Yeah. Brilliant. So that's really the end of General LeMay. So that's fun. But the point is, I guess, that Wallace begins, I mean, he's able to articulate people's anxieties, but he appears not the answer to disorder, but an embodiment of it. And I think he never surmounts that.
显然，这根本不符合华莱士选民的利益。所以就在那时他们说，把他送到越南去，希望他永远别回来。Yeah。太棒了。所以这真的是柯梅尔将军的结局。所以这很有趣。但我想重点是，华莱士开始时，我是说，他能够表达人们的焦虑，但他似乎不是混乱的解药，而是混乱的化身。我认为他永远无法克服这一点。
That's what stops him really breaking through. Because there's a kind of quality of kookiness. Yeah, the aggression. That's why LeMay is so damaging. Exactly. And by the end of the campaign, he's really being hammered by both sides, by the Democrats and the Republicans saying that he's wasted votes and all of this kind of thing. That said, you know, as the election approaches, he's still getting big crowds.
这才是真正阻碍他取得突破的原因。因为有一种古怪的特质。是的，那种侵略性。这就是为什么柯梅尔的负面影响如此之大。确切地说。到竞选结束时，他真的受到了两党的猛烈抨击，民主党和共和党都说他浪费了选票诸如此类。话虽如此，你知道，随着大选临近，他仍然吸引着庞大的人群。
He's still far ahead in the deep South States, Alabama, Louisiana, Mississippi. He's clearly going to win those. It's very tight in some of these other states. Everybody knows that the Wallace factor is so unpredictable that it's really impossible to call how this is going to break just before the election. I mean, he got 50,000 people on Boston Common. Okay, yeah. The epicenter of East Coast liberals.
他在深南部的几个州——阿拉巴马州、路易斯安那州、密西西比州——仍然遥遥领先。他显然会赢得这些州。在其他一些州，选情非常胶着。大家都知道华莱士因素极其不可预测，在大选前夕，局势到底会如何发展真的很难预料。我的意思是，他在波士顿公园吸引了5万人。好吧，是的。东海岸自由派的震中。
Exactly. And then the climax to his campaign, which I think reinforces the parallel with a more recent candidate, is at Madison Square Garden, 24th of October, so it's just a couple of weeks before election day. And this is an extraordinary scene and one that we have seen a lot of in recent years. So it's a 20,000 crowd sellout. It's the biggest rally in New York City since FDR in 1936. There are brass bands playing patriotic songs, there's country music, but there are also Klansmen, Minutemen, American Nazi party members. They're all demonstrating
没错。然后他竞选的高潮，我认为这强化了与一位更近期的候选人的相似之处，是在10月24日的麦迪逊广场花园，距离大选日只有几周时间。这是一个非凡的场景，也是我们在近年来经常看到的场景。这是一个全场爆满的2万人的集会。这是自1936年罗斯福总统以来纽约市最大规模的集会。铜管乐队演奏着爱国歌曲，有乡村音乐，但也有三K党成员、民兵成员、美国纳粹党成员。他们都在进行示威
outside to show their support. There are also counter demonstrators chanting see Kyle. Okay, so that's the Hitler stuff. Shouting that he's a Nazi and the police separating them. And Wallace comes out to speak and at first it's such an enormous occasion that he's a little bit hesitant actually, even possibly nervous. But then the first protest starts. It's a black guy who hands up a poster with a Klansman and the noose, the slogan says, law and order Wallace style. And then there are people with megaphones, bull horns as our American listeners would call them. And the crowd goes mad at these
在外面以示支持。还有高喊“西卡尔”（音译）的反示威者。好吧，那就是希特勒那一套。大喊他是纳粹，警察把他们隔开。华莱士出来讲话，起初这是一个如此盛大的场合，以至于他实际上有点犹豫，甚至可能有点紧张。但接着第一场抗议开始了。是一个黑人举着一张海报，上面画着一个三K党成员和绞索，标语写着“华莱士风格的法律与秩序”。然后有人拿着扩音器，也就是我们的美国听众所称的扩音器。人群对这些人疯狂呐喊
guys. The police have to wade in to separate fights. And Wallace is galvanized by this. He gives this very famous line. He says says why do the leaders of the two national parties count out of these anarchists? One of them laid down in front of President Johnson's limousine last year I tell you when November comes the first time they lie down in front of my limousine It'll be the last limousine they ever lay down in front of and everyone goes way. Yeah, they're delighted But again, it's that thing about violence and that's the first of 12 standing evasions. He does all his usual sort of rhetorical tricks. He says, you know, the reason we don't have riots in Alabama is as soon as someone picks
警察不得不介入拉开打架的人。华莱士被此激起了斗志。他说出了那句非常著名的台词。他说为什么两大政党的领袖要迎合这些无政府主义者？其中一人去年躺在约翰逊总统的豪华轿车前面，我告诉你们，当11月到来时，他们第一次躺在我的豪华轿车前面，这将是他们永远躺在前面的最后一次豪华轿车，每个人都发出“哇”的惊叹。是的，他们很高兴。但话说回来，这就是关于暴力的事，那是12次起立鼓掌中的第一次。他使出了他所有惯常的修辞伎俩。他说，你知道，我们在阿拉巴马州没有发生暴动的原因是，一旦有人拿起
up a brick, they get a bullet in their brain and everyone's, hey, that's brilliant. You know, let's shoot more people, all of this stuff. One thing actually buried in the speech that I noticed when I re-read it that I had not thought about before, he says, we should have looked our allies in Western Europe in the face and said to them, you should go into Vietnam. And if you don't go in in Southeast Asia, we're not only going to cut off every dime of foreign aid you are getting, we're going to ask you to pay back all you owe us from World War I right to this very day.
一块砖头，他们的脑子里就会挨上一颗子弹，每个人都想，太棒了。你知道，多射杀几个人，诸如此类。事实上，我重读演讲时注意到其中埋藏的一件事，是我以前从未想过的，他说，我们本应该直视西欧盟友的脸，对他们说，你们应该去越南。如果你们不去东南亚，我们不仅要切断你们得到的每一分钱的外援，我们还要要求你们偿还自第一次世界大战以来直到今天所欠我们的一切债务。
And that sounds very, very familiar. Anyway, we've been talking too long about George Wallace. We will get to the last days of the election at the end of this series. He doesn't become president. His support is squeezed in the final days, but he does, as I said at the beginning, he wants five states and he wins 10 million votes. And I think he really, really matters. And just to sum up the story about why he matters,
这听起来非常非常熟悉。不管怎样，我们谈论乔治·华莱士的时间太长了。我们将在本系列结束时谈到大选的最后几天。他没有当选总统。他的支持率在最后几天被挤压了，但他确实像我一开始说的，他赢得了5个州和1000万张选票。我认为他真的非常非常重要。为了总结他为什么重要的故事，
I'll tell you what happened after the election. So one of Richard Nixon's campaign staff was a guy called Kevin Phillips, guy in his 20s, very smart. He was always looking at data. And his argument, he believed that Wallace was the canary in the coal mine for American political life. And he argued, Phillips, he said, American politics is fundamentally changing for two reasons.
我来告诉你们大选后发生了什么。理查德·尼克松的一位竞选工作人员是一个叫凯文·菲利普斯的家伙，二十多岁，非常聪明。他一直在研究数据。他的论点是，他认为华莱士是美国政治生活中的“煤矿里的金丝雀”。他争辩说，菲利普斯，他说，美国政治正在发生根本性的变化，原因有二。
Number one, the center of gravity, which was always the kind of Northeast, is moving South and it's moving to a region that Phillips, he called it the sunbelt, a region that is being transformed by air conditioning and things, lots of defense contractors, lots of new industries in these places, Arizona, California, Texas, Tennessee, the Carolinas. This is the heartland now. This is the battleground. And the second thing he thought was, he said, white working-class voters are
第一，一直作为某种东北部中心的重心正在向南移动，正在向一个菲利普斯称之为“阳光地带”的地区移动，这是一个因空调等事物而发生巨变的地区，这里有大量的国防承包商，有大量的新兴产业，在亚利桑那州、加利福尼亚州、得克萨斯州、田纳西州、卡罗来纳州。这就是现在的心脏地带。这就是战场。他认为的第二件事是，他说，白人工人阶级选民将
going to leave the Democratic party and they're going to have to find somewhere to go. And he felt that the prize was to get people who'd voted for Wallace to make the next step and to vote Republican. To find a line that would not repel people because it was obviously racist, but it would bring in the white South and it would also bring in Italian Americans, Irish Americans, Eastern Europeans, Poles, all this stuff. And he published this in a book called the emerging Republican majority in 1969. And he gave a copy to Nixon and Nixon read it and he said, brilliant, we'll do it.
要离开民主党，他们必须找到一个去处。他觉得关键是要让那些投了华莱士票的人迈出下一步，去投票支持共和党。找到一条不会让人反感、因为其具有明显的种族主义色彩的路线，但它能拉拢美国南部的白人，也能拉拢意大利裔美国人、爱尔兰裔美国人、东欧人、波兰人等等。他在1969年出版的一本名为《正在崛起的共和党多数》的书里发表了这一观点。他送了一本给尼克松，尼克松读后说，太棒了，我们就这么干。
And a few months later, Nixon started for the first time, bringing country musicians to perform in the white house. There's a canary in a coal mine. There is a canary in a coal mine because of course it worked. In 1972, every single Wallace state voted for Nixon. In 1980, all of them except Jimmy Carter's home state of Georgia, voted for Reagan. In 2000, every single one of them voted for George Bush. And in 2016 and in 2020, they voted for Donald Trump. In 1968, Norman Mailer was writing about Wallace and he said,
几个月后，尼克松开始破天荒地请乡村音乐家到白宫表演。煤矿里真的有金丝雀。煤矿里确实有金丝雀，因为这当然奏效了。1972年，每一个华莱士支持过的州都投票给了尼克松。1980年，除了吉米·卡特的家乡佐治亚州外，所有这些州都投票给了里根。2000年，他们中的每一个都投票给了小布什。在2016年和2020年，他们都投票给了唐纳德·特朗普。1968年，诺曼·梅勒在谈到华莱士时说，
voted for Donald Trump. In 1968, Norman Mailer was writing about Wallace and he said, America might not be ready for George Wallace, but it might be waiting for a super Wallace. And Tom, I think he was right. Yeah. Well, that was brilliant Dominic. Thanks so much. Absolutely fascinating. But listeners, the drama of 1968 in America, still long way to go. Two more episodes. So in our next episode, we will be in Chicago with the Democrats for one of the most dramatic and violent showdowns in American political history. So yippee. And then in our final episode, we will be looking at the election itself and Richard Nixon, who is trying to make the most dramatic comeback in American political history, perhaps. And if you can't wait for those, then you can just go to the restishistory.com and join the club and get them immediately.
投票给了唐纳德·特朗普。1968年，诺曼·梅勒在谈到华莱士时说，美国可能还没有为乔治·华莱士做好准备，但它可能在等待一个“超级华莱士”。汤姆，我认为他是对的。嗯，多米尼克，讲得太棒了。非常感谢。绝对引人入胜。但是听众朋友们，1968年美国的戏剧性事件还远未结束。还有两集。所以在我们的下一集里，我们将和民主党人一起去芝加哥，经历美国政治史上最戏剧性、最暴力的对决之一。所以，太棒了。然后在我们的最后一集里，我们将关注大选本身以及理查德·尼克松，他试图制造美国政治史上也许最戏剧性的卷土重来。如果你等不及这些，你可以直接去 restishistory.com 加入俱乐部并立即收看。
So until next time, goodbye. Cheerio. time. Goodbye. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
那么直到下次，再见。再见。时间。再见。本集暂无评论。点击文字记录中的任意句子即可发表评论。